Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. Fondly do we hope. Fervently do we pray that this mighty scourge of war may speedily pass away. Yet, if God wills, that it continue until all the wealth piled by the bondsman's 250 years of unrequited toil shall be sunk,
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 the restishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是说，the restishistory.com。我们深情地希望，我们热切地祈祷，这场可怕的战争灾难能够迅速过去。然而，如果上帝愿意，让这场战争一直持续下去，直到奴隶在过去250年中不计回报的劳累所堆积的全部财富被消耗殆尽，
until every drop of blood drawn with the lash shall be paid by another drawn with the sword. as was said three thousand years ago, so still it must be said, the judgments of the Lord are true and righteous altogether. With malice toward none, with charity for all, with firmness in the right as God gives us to see the right. Let us strive on to finish the work we are in, to bind up the nation's wound. to care for him who shall have borne the battle
直到皮鞭抽出的每一滴血都用刀剑流出的血来偿还，正如三千年前所说的那样，现在也必须这样说，主的判决完全是真实而正义的。以怨报德，有爱心予众人，在上帝让我们看到正义的地方坚定正义。让我们继续努力完成我们正在进行的工作，抚平国家的创伤。照顾那些经历过战斗的人
and for his widow and his orphan to do all which may achieve and cherish a just and lasting peace among ourselves and with all nations. The unmistakable tones there of Daniel Day Lewis playing Abraham Lincoln of course and Abe was speaking there at his second inauguration as president of the United States on the 4th of March 1865.
照顾他的遗孀和孤儿，为实现并维护我们之间以及所有国家之间公正持久的和平而尽一切努力。当然，刚才那毫无疑问的语调来自丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯饰演的亚伯拉罕·林肯，亚伯拉罕当时是在1865年3月4日美国总统就职典礼上发表讲话。
And Dominic, it is a great supreme moment of triumph, isn't it? Lincoln has just been re-elected, and victory for the North, for the Union that Lincoln has been leading throughout the Civil War is just weeks away. But what's amazing about that speech is how muted any sense of triumphalism is. It's regarded by Lincoln Scholars as one of his greatest speeches. There's no sort of sense of boasting. and no sense of exaltation and glory. We've won!
多米尼克，这是一个极其伟大的胜利时刻，不是吗？林肯刚刚当选连任，对于北方而言，对于林肯在整个内战期间一直领导的联邦而言，胜利仅在几周之后。但那篇演讲最令人惊叹的是，那种凯旋主义的情绪是多么的微弱。林肯学者们认为这是他最伟大的演讲之一。没有什么吹嘘的感觉，
Yee! I mean, there's none of that. Well, that would have been very unlike Lincoln, to be fair. There's a great sense of melancholy, I think, to it. Sadness at the cost, humility, I think, in the face of God's divine plan. And this emphasis on union and reconciliation and binding up the wounds of the war. So his biographer Michael Burlingame, who wrote, I have to say, I mean, it's genuinely, it's about a 10,000-page biography. and it's so long that a lot of it was cut out.
没有那种欣喜若狂和荣耀感。我们赢了！耶！我的意思是，完全没有那种感觉。嗯，说实话，这很不像林肯的风格。我认为其中有一种巨大的忧郁感。为付出的代价感到悲伤，面对上帝神圣计划时的谦逊。以及对联邦、和解以及抚平战争创伤的这种强调。所以他的传记作家迈克尔·伯林盖姆，写了——我必须说，我的意思是，它真的大约有一万页长，
So he put it all online. That is such Sambrook behaviour. It is very Sanbrot behaviour. But it's American biographical behaviour, isn't it? Because an American biographer cannot see a life and not write a 10,000-page biography of him. Yeah, exactly. They basically want to put down every single fact.
太长了以至于很多内容都被删掉了。所以他把全部内容都放到了网上。这真是萨姆布鲁克式的行为。这确实是很萨姆布鲁克式的行为。但这也就是美国传记作家的行为，不是吗？因为一个美国传记作家不可能看到一个人的一生而不为他写上一万页的传记。是的，完全如此。他们基本上想把每一个事实都记录下来。
That's what I intend to do in this podcast, Tom, actually. Brilliant. That's something for us all to look forward to. I'll tell you a good fact that's in his biography. They gave me great pleasure. Lincoln's inaugural got grave reviews in our own country, England. The spectator said that in its dignity and principle it was worthy of the greatest of politicians, namely Oliver Cromwell. Wow, you don't get higher praise than that, do you?
汤姆，这实际上也是我在这档播客中打算做的。太棒了。这让我们大家都有所期待了。我告诉你一个存在于他的传记中的好事实。这让我感到非常高兴。林肯的就职演说在我们的祖国英国得到了严厉的评价。《旁观者》杂志称，从其尊严和原则来看，它堪称最伟大的政治家当之无愧，也就是奥利弗·克伦威尔。哇，你得不到比这更高的赞誉了，对吧？
You don't get higher praise. Very much a friend of the show. Right. Now, at this moment that Lincoln gives this speech, he has only 42 days to live. So we thought this week we would tell the story of his final days of his last, his last, his last theatrical. theatrical outing at Ford's theatre and then the hunt for his assassin John Wilkes Booth and we
你确实得不到更高的赞誉了。绝对是节目的好朋友。好啦。现在，在林肯发表这篇演讲的时刻，他只剩下42天可活了。所以我们觉得本周我们要讲述他最后日子的故事，讲述他最后一次，最后一次，最后一次戏剧活动，即在福特剧院的戏剧活动，然后是对他的刺客约翰·威尔克斯·布斯的搜捕，我们
wanted to do it I think not least because it would allow us to reintegrate into the show one of our favourite characters literally as mad as a hatter, top eunuch Boston Corbett I mean for any fan of eunuchs this is going to be the high point of the series I think definitely and it comes at the end so
之所以想这样做，我想不仅仅是因为这能让我们将我们最喜欢的角色之一重新融入节目中——这个家伙简直疯得像个帽匠，顶级太监波士顿·科比特。我的意思是，对于任何太监迷来说，这将是本系列的高潮，我认为绝对如此，而且它发生在最后，所以
stay tuned exactly so if you want to jump ahead just join the rest of history club at the restisistry.com and you can hear that right now don't it done like a master Okay. So a bit of context for those of you still with us. The American Civil War has been raging since April 1861. But in the last couple of years, the massive economic and kind of manpower and industrial advantages of the North, marshalled by Ulysses S. Grant, have begun to tell. Tom, we were talking about Grant before the show, weren't we? We agreed both boring and corrupt. It's never a good combination. Because if you have corruption, you want people to be flamboyant and interesting. Not just dull, kind of. handing out money to post offices and things.
敬请期待。没错，所以如果你想提前了解，只需在 the restishistory.com 加入“一切皆历史”俱乐部，你现在就可以听到这个。干得漂亮，大师。好了。对于那些仍然和我们在一起的人来说，提供一点背景信息。美国内战自1861年4月以来一直在激烈进行。但在过去几年里，由尤利西斯·S·格兰特统帅的北方在庞大的经济、人力和工业方面的优势开始显现出来了。汤姆，我们在节目开始前讨论过格兰特，对吧？我们一致认为他既无聊又腐败。这从来都不是一个好组合。因为如果你有腐败，你会希望人们艳丽张扬、有趣。而不仅仅是沉闷地把钱分给邮局之类的机构。
American listeners won't like that because they think Grant is brilliant and marshalling industrial resources. Well, I tell you who else went like that is Daniel Jackson, friend of the show, The Voice of the Northeast of the North East, who's a big fan of Ulysses S. Grant, because Ulysses S. Grant went to Newcastle, I believe. Exactly, exactly. Anyway, let's get back to the story. At the end of 1864, the Union Army captured Atlanta, key moments in the war, General Sherman, who people may remember from our Custer series, makes this famous march to the see that basically tears a hole in the economic and kind of transport networks of the
美国听众不会喜欢这样，因为他们认为格兰特非常了不起，并且在调配工业资源方面很出色。嗯，我告诉你另一个有这种想法的人是丹尼尔·杰克逊，节目的好朋友，“东北之声”，他是尤利西斯·S·格兰特的超级粉丝，因为尤利西斯·S·格兰特去过纽卡斯尔，我相信。完全正确，完全正确。无论如何，让我们回到故事中来。在1864年底，联邦军队攻占了亚特兰大，这是战争中的关键时刻，谢尔曼将军——大家可能还从我们的卡斯特系列节目中记得他——进行了这次著名的向大海进军，这基本上在经济和交通网络上给
Confederacy. So from that point on, the Confederacy really is on borrowed time. And the one hope the Confederates had, the one hope the Slave South had, was that Lincoln would lose his re-election bid in November to the Democrat candidate George McClellan. Now, the Democrats wanted an end to the war immediately in a negotiated settlement with the Confederacy. But Lincoln won that election pretty comfortably, so now everybody knows that the war is going to be fought to the bitter end. Is there never any thought on the part of, say, Jefferson Davis, the Confederate president and his entourage, that they might assassinate Lincoln?
邦联撕开了一个大洞。所以从那时起，邦联的日子真的屈指可数了。邦联人唯一的希望，蓄奴南方唯一的希望，就是林肯在11月的竞选连任中输给民主党候选人乔治·麦克莱伦。现在，民主党人希望通过与邦联达成谈判协议来立即结束战争。但林肯相当轻松地赢得了那场选举，所以现在每个人都知道这场战争将打到苦涩的尽头。比如杰斐逊·戴维斯，邦联总统和他的随行人员，他们有没有哪怕一瞬间想过刺杀林肯？
That's never discussed. Not among the Confederate leaders, but in Confederate newspapers, as we shall see, there is a lot of talk of this, and there is an analogy they use that will please you greatly. because it plays to your strengths. Incidentally, I read on the Reddit today with somebody complaining there's too much talk of Julius Caesar in the rest of history. So there is a spoiler alert
这从未被讨论过。在邦联领袖中没有讨论过，但在邦联报纸中，正如我们将会看到的，有很多关于此事的讨论，而且他们使用了一个类比，这会让你非常高兴，因为这发挥了你的长处。顺便说一句，我今天在红迪网上看到有人抱怨在《一切皆历史》中关于尤利西斯·恺撒的谈论太多了。所以这里有一个关于将要做出的比较的剧透预警，
about the comparison that will be made. So to get back to the inauguration, the scene, I mean, this is an extraordinary moment for Lincoln. Lincoln is the first president to win re-election since Andrew Jackson back in 1832. So winning re-election is actually quite unusual in American politics in the 19th century. That's interesting because it's the opposite
回到就职典礼，这个场景，我的意思是，这对林肯来说是一个非凡的时刻。林肯是自1832年安德鲁·杰克逊以来第一位赢得连任的总统。所以在19世纪的美国政治中，赢得连任实际上是非常罕见的。这很有趣，因为这与
it to 20th century, isn't it? Exactly. Basically, in the 19th century, people just want to throw the president out as quickly as possible, I think, by and large. Now, Lincoln is a very unexpected person to even be president. He'd been born into poverty in Kentucky in 1809. He'd grown up in a log cabin, which becomes a very important part of his mythology. He's self-educated. Initially, he was going to be a blacksmith, but he ends up a kind of prairie lawyer. He becomes active in state politics in Illinois. He then becomes a prominent figure in the new anti-slavery Republican Party in the 1850s, and when he's nominated by the Republicans as their presidential candidate in 1860, it's quite unexpected.
20世纪相反，不是吗？没错。基本上，在19世纪，人们只是想尽快把总统赶下台，我认为大体上是这样的。现在，林肯甚至成为总统也是一个非常出人意料的人。他于1809年出生于肯塔基州的贫困家庭。他在一个原木小屋里长大，这后来成了他神话中非常重要的一部分。他是自学成才的。最初，他打算成为一名铁匠，但最终他成了一名草原律师。他开始活跃于伊利诺伊州的州政治中。然后他在1850年代成为新兴的反奴隶制共和党的重要人物，当他在1860年被共和党提名为总统候选人时，这是相当出乎意料的。
He's not really, he's not a top-tier household name. But he wins the presidency, and that's the trigger for the slave-owning southern states, who are outraged by his elevation, to secede from the union and to form the Confederacy. So Lincoln is propelled into this position that's unprecedented in American history. He is facing one of the world's first modern industrialized conflicts. So it's a conflict of railroads and steamships and trenches and prison camps, all of these kinds of things that kills about 700,000 people. So something he could never have anticipated even before running for president.
他其实并不是一个顶尖的家喻户晓的名字。但他赢得了总统大选，这成为了蓄奴的南方各州脱离联邦并组建邦联的导火索，这些州对他的上位感到愤怒。因此，林肯被推到了美国历史上前所未有的位置。他面临着世界上第一场现代工业化冲突之一。所以这是一场铁路、轮船、战壕和战俘营的冲突，所有这些夺去了大约70万生命的东西。所以这是他在竞选总统之前绝对无法预料的事情。
Anyway, this is his second inauguration. Now, you would expect it under those circumstances to be a very solemn and serious occasion, befitting his rhetoric. But you know what? What I love about this is Charles Dickens would have very much enjoyed it because he's not an admirer of 19th century America. So it's like a scene from Martin Chuzzlewit. It is like a scene from Martin Chuzzlewit. Basically, so it's pouring with rain.
无论如何，这是他的第二次就职典礼。现在，在这种情况下，你本会期望这是一个非常庄严和严肃的场合，符合他的修辞。但你知道吗？我喜欢这一点的地方在于查尔斯·狄更斯会非常喜欢它，因为他不是19世纪美国的崇拜者。所以这就像《马丁·查多维特》中的一个场景。这确实就像《马丁·查多维特》中的一个场景。基本上，外面下着倾盆大雨。
There are far too many people. There's massive crowds. The capital is overwhelmed. And the place is packed with women in long, muddy, sodden skirts, sort of wrestling for places in the gallery. Now, Lincoln has picked a new vice president to balance the ticket, create a sense of national unity. and this is a guy from Tennessee called Andrew Johnson. So he's a former Democrat, and he's actually from a Confederate slave state. And Dominic, it's important that listeners don't muddle him up with Andrew Jackson, isn't it?
人太多了。人群人山人海。国会大厦人满为患。到处都是穿着长长的、泥泞的、湿透的裙子的女人，她们在看台上的座位上争夺着。现在，林肯挑选了一位新的副总统来平衡候选人名单，营造一种国家团结的感觉，这是一个来自田纳西州的人，名叫安德鲁·约翰逊。所以他曾是一名民主党人，而且他实际上来自一个邦联蓄奴州。多米尼克，听众们千万不要把他和安德鲁·杰克逊搞混，对吧？
Who came earlier. Or Lyndon Johnson. So he's just Andrew Johnson. This is his own man, Tom. He's had typhoid, so he's very weak. And to try and sort of steady himself, he drinks three glasses of brandy. And the brandy goes completely to his head, and he absolutely disgraces himself by making this interminable and rambling speech.
他来得更早。或者林登·约翰逊。所以他只是安德鲁·约翰逊。汤姆，这是他自己的人。他得过伤寒，所以他非常虚弱。为了稳住自己，他喝了三杯白兰地。白兰地完全冲昏了他的头脑，他发表了一场又长又乱的演讲，彻底丢尽了脸面。
He keeps forgetting everyone's names. At one point, he grabs the Bible and starts slobbering over and kissing it. Then he just won't stop talking. So he's like gussy-finknottel after drinking the vodka-laced orange juice in P.G. Woodhouse. The New York World, the reporter on the inauguration, said he defiled our council chamber with the spewings of a drunken boar, which I like. So then Lincoln gives his speech, brilliant. He tried to raise the tone.
他一直记不住每个人的名字。有一刻，他抓起圣经，开始流着口水亲吻它。然后他就没完没了地讲个不停。所以他就像P.G.伍德豪斯笔下喝了加伏特加的橙汁的格西·芬克诺特一样。《纽约世界报》的一位就职典礼记者说，他用一个醉公猪的呕吐物玷污了我们的议事大厅，我挺喜欢这个形容的。所以接着林肯发表了他的演讲，非常精彩。他试图提升基调。
Then there's the inauguration banquet. and the crowd go completely bonkers and I quote they pushed the tables from their places snatched off whole turkeys and loaves of cake smashed crockery and glassware spilled oyster and terrapin on each other's heads
然后是就职宴会，人群彻底疯狂了，我引述一下：“他们把桌子从原位推开，抢走整只火鸡和整块蛋糕，砸碎陶器和玻璃器皿，把生蚝和拟鳄龟汤泼到彼此的头上”，
ruined costly dresses and made the floor sticky with food and if you've ever been to an American buffet you will recognise this behaviour I think I've been to an American buffet I've never seen guests pouring terrapin over each other's heads on each other's heads
毁了昂贵的礼服，让地板粘满食物。如果你去过美国自助餐，你会认出这种行为的，我想。我去过美国自助餐，但我从未见过客人把拟鳄龟汤倒在彼此的头上，倒在彼此的头上。
you'd have to be holding the terrapin up quite high quite a big ask There's actually one nice moment, which is the great black abolitionist, Frederick Douglass, turns up at the White House reception. He's turned away because he's black. And Lincoln hears reports of this and he says, no, no, no, have him in, have him in. And then he makes a great show showman, isn't he? Yeah, he's a great showman and he's also a nice person. So that reflects well on Lincoln, I think. But everybody is really struck at the time. They say Lincoln looks awful. He looks absolutely shattered. Chicago Tribune, the listeners. were painfully impressed with his gaunt skeleton-like appearance. And this is not because, like you, Tom, he spends all his time in the gym. But I don't have a gaunt skeleton-like appearance. I glow with health.
你得把拟鳄龟汤举得相当高才行，这要求挺高的。实际上有一个温馨的时刻，那就是伟大的黑人废奴主义者弗雷德里克·道格拉斯出现在白宫招待会上。他因为是黑人而被拒之门外。林肯听到了这方面的汇报，他说：“不，不，不，让他进来，让他进来。”然后他表现得像个伟大的表演大师，不是吗？是的，他是个伟大的表演大师，而且他也是个好人。所以这给林肯树立了良好的形象，我认为。但当时每个人都真的大为震惊。他们说林肯看起来糟糕透了。他看起来完全精疲力竭。《芝加哥论坛报》的听众们，对他的憔悴如骷髅般的外表留下了痛苦的印象。这并不是因为像你一样，汤姆，他把所有时间都花在健身房里。但我并没有憔悴如骷髅般的外表。我散发着健康的光彩。
That's the difference. Oh, is that the difference? Okay, right. I'm glad we've cleared that up. He is, like you, he's in his late 50s, is that fair to say? And working under unprecedented pressure, there is a point of similarity. What about this bit? He strikes visitors as grey, lined and haggard.
这就是区别。哦，这就是区别吗？好吧，对。我很高兴我们弄清楚了这一点。他和你一样，已经快五十岁了，这么说公平吗？而且在空前的压力下工作，这一点有相似之处。这段怎么样？他给来访者的印象是灰白、满脸皱纹且面容憔悴。
No, that's not me. So he's absolutely shattered. And it's not just about the war. It's about the pressure of Washington politics. So Washington politics, at this point, it's an intensely kind of faction-ridden, disputatious place. And part of this is because the war has placed unprecedented demands on the American system. So, you know, the federal government is being asked to do things this has never done before. But also, they're confronting absolutely existential challenges.
不，那不是我。所以他彻底筋疲力尽了。这不仅仅是因为战争。这是华盛顿政治的压力。所以在华盛顿政治中，在这个时候，这是一个高度充满派系斗争、好争辩的地方。部分原因是因为战争给美国体制带来了空前的要求。所以，你知道，联邦政府被要求做它以前从未做过的事情。但同时，它们也面临着绝对生死存亡的挑战。
What are they going to do about slavery and what are they going to do about the rebel states of the South? So on slavery, the House of Representatives has just approved something called the 13th Amendment. If you've seen the film, Lincoln, the Stephen Spielberg film, this is a big part of that story. So they've passed the 13th Amendment and the states have just begun to approve it. So about 18 of them, I think, have approved it by the time of Lincoln's inauguration. So the bigger question now is what on earth do you do with the Confederate South once they've lost? Now, for weeks, Lincoln has been striking quite a conciliatory note. in February he had met Confederate negotiators on a steamer anchored in the Hampton Roads
他们要如何处理奴隶制问题，他们要如何处理南方的叛乱各州？关于奴隶制，众议院刚刚批准了一项名为《第十三修正案》的法案。如果你看过电影《林肯》，史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的电影，这就是那个故事的重要部分。所以他们通过了《第十三修正案》，各州刚刚开始批准它。所以到林肯就职时，我想大约有18个州批准了它。所以现在更大的问题是，一旦邦联南方战败，你到底该拿他们怎么办？几周以来，林肯一直表现出相当调解的姿态。在2月份，他在停泊在汉普顿罗兹的一艘轮船上会见了邦联谈判代表，
and they'd had these talks and he had really gone out of his way to seem immoliant. He had actually said, you know, if you will rejoin the Union, I will look into ways in which you can be recompensed for the abolition of slavery. Southern slaveholders would be compensated with northern taxes for their financial losses. and a lot of listeners may find that puzzling given that they've been fighting the war but one of his friends said the one thing that Lincoln feared
他们进行了这些会谈，他真的竭尽全力显得通情达理。他实际上说过，你知道，如果你重新加入联邦，我会寻找方法，让你们在废除奴隶制方面得到补偿。南方的奴隶主将用北方的税收来弥补他们的经济损失。许多听众可能会觉得这很费解，考虑到他们一直在打这场仗，但他的朋友说，林肯唯一害怕的事情
was anarchy in the South when the Confederacy breaks up what he doesn't want is the whole thing to fall apart in chaos what he wants is to close the war upon such terms as would make the southern people and southern soldiers
是南方的无政府状态。当邦联解体时，他最不希望看到整个局势陷入混乱。他希望以这样的条款结束战争，使南方人民和南方士兵
think somewhat kindly of the union to which they were brought back by force of arms in other words we will welcome the prodigal son back into the family it's what you'd expect though isn't it Because I know that all the various reasons for which the Civil War is fought, but one of them surely must be to preserve the strength and integrity of the United States
对他们通过武力被带回的联邦产生一些好感。换句话说，我们将欢迎浪子回头回到家庭中。不过，这正是你所期望的，不是吗？因为我知道进行内战的各种原因，但其中之一肯定是为了维护美国的实力和完整，
and keep it as a continental power. So you absolutely have to make the defeated Confederates feel like they are Americans once again. Because otherwise you've defeated the entire purpose of what you've been fighting for. Abraham Lincoln would agree with you. Abraham Lincoln would absolutely agree with you. However, a lot of people in his own party would not. So these are people who are called the radical Republicans and quite a lot of them are actually saying
并将其保持为一个大陆强国。所以你绝对必须让战败的邦联人再次觉得自己是美国人。因为否则你就违背了你一直在为之奋斗的全部目的。亚伯拉罕·林肯会同意你的看法。亚伯拉罕·林肯绝对会同意你的看法。然而，他自己党内的许多人却不会。所以这些人被称为激进共和党人，其中相当多的人实际上在说
there should be no clemency for the traitors at all. Lincoln's own vice president, Andrew Johnson, who's not a radical Republican, but I think partly because he is from the South and there's a lot of kind of internal feuding going on among Southerners, he says treason must be made odious. In other words, the traitors must be punished and impoverished. So in other words, go hard on them.
根本不应对叛国者有任何宽大处理。林肯自己的副总统安德鲁·约翰逊并不是激进的共和党人，但我想部分是因为他来自南方，南方人内部存在很多内斗，他说叛乱必须被视为可憎的。换句话说，叛国者必须受到惩罚并变得一无所有。换句话说，对他们严厉一点。
That's actually not how it turns out when he's president. So you've got the radical Republicans saying, go much harder on them. Lincoln's too weak. And on the other side, you've got moderates and Democrats who say, actually, you know, Lincoln's endanger being too harsh. We should readmit the southern states as quickly as possible. Don't expect them to behave in a very nice way to their former slaves. Wind up the military administrations in the South, all of this kind of thing. So Lincoln is the centrist in this? There are huge arguments going on, which we don't massively need to go into. Between Lincoln and the radicals about, you know, what's the
但当他成为总统时，事情实际并非如此。所以激进的共和党人说，对他们要严厉得多。林肯太软弱了。而在另一边，温和派和民主党人说，实际上，你知道，林肯有过于严厉的危险。我们应该尽快重新接纳南方各州。不要指望它们对以前的奴隶表现得很好。结束南方的军事管辖，诸如此类的事情。所以林肯是其中的中间派？这里发生了巨大的争论，我们没必要深入探讨。林肯与激进派之间关于，你知道，是什么
oath that you will get the Confederates to swear. How many voters in former Confederate states will have to take an oath of allegiance and pledge to support the Union and all this kind of thing? One other explosive issue, who will get to vote when the Confederacy is readmitted to the Union? Will former slaves be allowed to vote? Because as of 1864, virtually no black Americans can vote at all. There are a handful in New York, but there are very, very strict property qualifications. But of course, if you allow millions of newly enfranchised African-Americans to vote, that would completely change politics.
让南方同盟宣誓的誓言。前南方同盟各州会有多少选民必须宣誓效忠并承诺支持联邦以及诸如此类的事情？另一个爆炸性问题是，当南方同盟重新加入联邦时，谁能投票？以前的奴隶会被允许投票吗？因为到1864年，几乎没有黑人美国人能投票。纽约有少数人，但有非常非常严格的财产资格限制。但当然，如果你允许数百万新获得选举权的非裔美国人投票，那将彻底改变政治。
And in the Spielberg film, that is how they get the Gettysburg address in, isn't it? That Lincoln sits there and he talks to a black soldier who says, you know, we don't have the vote and then completes the, you know, he speaks the Gettysburg address. Exactly. And actually the black soldier, that's an important point. there have been almost 200,000 black Americans serving in the Union Army and privately, Lincoln has already told his friends, I think it's completely unreasonable for us to ask these men to fight and die for the Union,
在斯皮尔伯格的电影中，这就是他们融入葛底斯堡演说的方式，对吧？林肯坐在那里，与一个黑人士兵交谈，士兵说，你知道，我们没有投票权，然后完成了，你知道，他说出了葛底斯堡演说。完全正确。事实上，那个黑人士兵，这是一个重要的点。有将近20万黑人美国人在联邦军队服役，私下里，林肯已经告诉他的朋友们，我认为我们要求这些人流血牺牲来维护联邦，这是完全不合理的，
but then not to allow them to vote afterwards. So he's got a lot of challenges because these are very controversial issues. And I think it's partly because of the weight of this burden that he's very keen to get out of the city. So on the 20th of March, General Grant, who has cornered Robert E. Lee, the Confederates leading general in northern Virginia, Grant invites Lincoln to the front, says you want to come and see the action. You can see this in the film, Lincoln, Tabby's favorite film. The big disagreement with me and Tabby on this is I don't like that piano music that Americans love in in kind of Civil War documentaries and films. I find it offensively
但随后又不允许他们在事后投票。所以他面临着许多挑战，因为这些是非常有争议的问题。我想部分是因为这个沉重的负担，他非常渴望离开这座城市。所以在3月20日，格兰特将军将罗伯特·E·李（南方同盟在弗吉尼亚州北部的领军将领）逼入绝境，格兰特邀请林肯去前线，说你想来看看战斗吗。你可以在电影《林肯》中看到这一点，这是塔比最喜欢的电影。我和塔比对此最大的分歧在于，我不喜欢美国人在南北战争纪录片和电影中喜爱的的那种钢琴音乐。我觉得它冒犯性地
tinkly. Anyway, that's by the bye. He sails down on this steamer to go and see Grant. Now the big theme of this whole section is the horribleness of Lincoln's wife. So she's called Mary Todd Lincoln. I think the film doesn't capture what an absolute monster she is, which may sound harsh, but basically here's the scene.
叮当响。无论如何，闲话少叙。他乘这艘汽船顺流而下去看望格兰特。现在整个这一段的主题是林肯妻子有多可怕。她叫玛丽·托德·林肯。我认为电影没有捕捉到她是一个绝对的怪物，这听起来可能很苛刻，但基本上情景是这样的。
They've gone on this boat. It's called the River Queen. General Grant turns up with his wife, Julia. Grant and Lincoln go off to talk about the war, and Julia goes to sit down next to Mrs. Lincoln, and Mrs. Lincoln shrieks at her. How dare you be seated until I invite
他们坐上了这艘船。它叫“河后”号。格兰特将军和他的妻子朱莉娅出现了。格兰特和林肯去谈论战争，朱莉娅去在林肯夫人旁边坐下，林肯夫人对她尖叫。你怎么敢在我邀请你之前就坐下
you to sit down. And this is typical. This is how she carries on. So a friend of Julia Grant said afterwards, Mrs. Lincoln seemed insanely jealous of every person and everything. So a couple of days later, they go off riding to look at some battle or something. And another general's wife is there,
你坐下。这很典型。她就是这样行事的。所以朱莉娅·格兰特的朋克后来在事后说，林肯夫人对每个人和每件事都嫉妒得发狂。所以几天后，他们骑马去看某场战斗或其他什么。另一个将军的妻子也在那里，
General Ord's wife who's very good looking. And she ends up riding next to Lincoln. And when Mary Todd Lincoln sees this, she shrieks again. She says, what does that woman mean by riding next to the president? blah blah blah blah blah and mrs grant says to her i think it's just an accident don't worry about it and mary says oh i suppose you want to go to the whitehouse yourself do you oh i suppose you see yourself as the president's wife i think she sounds fun she sounds sassy she's worse than sussie
奥德将军的妻子长得非常好看。她最后挨着林肯骑马。当玛丽·托德·林肯看到这一幕时，她又尖叫起来。她说，那个女人挨着总统骑马是什么意思？巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉，格兰特夫人对她说，我想这只是个意外，别担心，玛丽说，哦，我猜你自己想去白宫吧？哦，我猜你把自己看作总统的夫人了吧？我觉得她听起来很有趣，她很时髦，她比苏西还要
dominant just to ask you has she i mean she has been under considerable pressure hasn't she she has but i mean her son has died because that's the yeah but come on tom but isn't she she's prostrated by that in a kind of very victorian manner and she is but it's the 19th century hasn't everybody's son died at some point I suppose so, but I don't know. I mean, maybe she's depressed or... I think it's generally agreed by other wives that she is a bit of a... What do you call? What's the word you use? A baggage. A baggage. So on this ride, they get to where they're going. And Mary Linking goes straight up to this Mrs. Ord. And one of Grant's officers watches and is appalled. He says, she positively insulted her. She called her vile names in the presence of a crowd of officers and asked what she meant by following up the president of a riding next to him. him. The poor woman burst into tears and inquired what she had done, but Mrs. Lincoln refused to
专横，只是问你，她，我的意思是她承受了相当大的压力，不是吗？她是，但我的意思是她的儿子已经死了，因为那是，是的，但是拜托，汤姆，难道她不是吗？她以一种非常维多利亚时代的方式被那个击垮了，她是，但那是19世纪，难道每个人的儿子都在某个时候死去了吗？我想是的，但我不知道。我的意思是，也许她抑郁了，或者……我想其他妻子普遍认为她有点像个……你叫什么？你用的词是什么？累赘。一个累赘。所以在这次骑马中，他们到达了目的地。玛丽·林肯径直走向这位奥德夫人。格兰特的一名军官看到了，大惊失色。他说，她公然侮辱了她。她在众多军官面前用恶毒的话辱骂她，并质问她跟着总统并挨着他骑马是什么意思。那个可怜的女人哭了起来，问她做了什么，但林肯夫人拒绝
be appeased and stormed until she was tired. Mrs. Grant tried to stand by her friend, and everybody was shocked and horrified. He then went on to say, in the next few days, Mrs. Lincoln repeatedly attacked her husband in the presence of officers because of Mrs. Ord. Lincoln bore it with an expression of pain and sadness which cut one to the heart, but with supreme calmness and dignity. And to give you a sense. I have cut down this story from the sort of a billion examples in Michael Burlingame's book. Another general, Carl Schert, said that Mrs. Lincoln was the greatest tragedy of Mr. Lincoln's existence. And does Mr. Lincoln agree with this? Does he think she's awful or does he secretly love her? I think of possibly a bit of both, actually. Do you know
被安抚，大发雷霆直到她累了。格兰特夫人试图支持她的朋友，每个人都感到震惊和惊恐。他接着说，在接下来的几天里，林肯夫人因为奥德夫人的事，在军官面前多次攻击她的丈夫。林肯以一种痛苦和悲伤的表情忍受着，这让人心碎，但带着极大的冷静和尊严。为了让你有个概念。我从迈克尔·柏林盖姆书中的大约十亿个例子中删减了这个故事。另一位将军卡尔·舒茨说，林肯夫人是林肯先生一生中最大的悲剧。林肯先生同意这一点吗？他认为她很糟糕还是他暗地里爱她？我想可能两者都有一些，实际上。你知道
what I think of? I think of that scene on the French aeroplane with Emmanuel Macron and his former teacher. Oh, where she punched him in the face? As he punches him in the face And he has an expression of sort of shock And then he arranges his features for the cameras I mean Macaron loves his wife So maybe Lincoln loved his wife, I don't know Anyway, Lincoln spends a few days at the front
我想到了什么？我想到了法国飞机上埃马纽埃尔·马克龙和他的前老师的那个场景。哦，她扇了他脸一巴掌的地方？当她扇了他脸一巴掌时，他露出了某种震惊的表情，然后他在镜头前整理了自己的面部表情。我的意思是马克龙爱他的妻子，所以也许林肯爱他的妻子，我不知道。无论如何，林肯在前线呆了几天
He's very sort of melancholy There's a nice point which I think is in the film Where he's sitting around a campfire with Grant And Grant says Mr President, did you at any time Doubt the final success of the cause And Lincoln says, oh, never for a moment Yeah, never for a moment
他非常忧郁，有一个很好的点，我想在电影里有，他坐在格兰特周围的篝火旁，格兰特说，总统先生，你在任何时候怀疑过事业的最终成功吗？林肯说，哦，从来没有过一刻，是的，从来没有过一刻
But most of the time he's actually saying oh, the horrors of war, I really hope this is the end now. I feel terrible about all the people that died. He tells the story about seeing a Confederate soldier, a young soldier dying. When he's telling people about this, he kind of chokes up and he says, oh, I feel so terrible. We've cheated, we've robbed both the cradle and the grave. In other words, both the very young and the very old. We have fed them into the mincing machine of our kind of military operation. And at one point, actually, General Sherman arrives, and they're talking about the next battle. And Lincoln says to Sherman and Grant, more bloodshed, really? Can't we avoid this battle? And they say to him,
但大多数时候他实际上在说，哦，战争的恐怖，我真希望现在这就是结束。我对所有死去的人感到难过。他讲了一个看到一个南方同盟士兵、一个年轻士兵垂死的故事。当他向人们讲述这件事时，他有点哽咽，他说，哦，我觉得太可怕了。我们欺骗了，我们掠夺了摇篮和坟墓。换句话说，既有极年轻的也有极年老的。我们把他们喂进了我们那种军事行动的绞肉机。而且实际上，在某个时刻，谢尔曼将军到达了，他们在谈论下一场战斗。林肯对谢尔曼和格兰特说，又是流血事件，真的吗？我们难道不能避免这场战斗吗？他们对他说，
well, you know, it's not really up to us. It's up to the Confederates. If the Confederates surrender, we will be able to sort of crack on and forget it. Now, as it happens, the noose is tightening around the Confederates all the time. On the 2nd of April, while he's going on these trips, the Confederates are forced to evacuate their capital, Richmond, Virginia, which then lies open to the Union forces. And the next day, the Confederate defenses at a place called Petersburg are broken. and General Lee's army has to fall back across the Appomattox River. So the end is only days away.
嗯，你知道，这其实不取决于我们。这取决于南方同盟。如果南方同盟投降，我们将能够继续前进并忘掉它。现在，碰巧的是，绞索一直在勒紧南方同盟。4月2日，当他进行这些旅行时，南方同盟被迫撤离了他们的首都弗吉尼亚州里士满，该首都随后向联邦军队敞开。第二天，彼得斯堡一个地方的南方同盟防御被突破，李将军的军队不得不撤回到阿波马托克斯河对岸。所以结局只有几天之遥。
And on the 4th of April, so two days after the Confederate evacuation, Lincoln actually goes to the Confederate capital to Richmond. It is an extraordinary moment. I don't actually remember this in the Spielberg film. Lincoln has been dreaming of this moment all these years and he says to his aides, it seems to me that I've been dreaming a horrid dream for four years and now the nightmare is gone. And he goes with his son called Tad or Taddy. He is his youngest boy. He's celebrating his 12th birthday. He had a cleft palate and he suffered from a very severe speech impediment. So it's a kind of sad story with Tad. And they travel on this boat, the River Queen,
4月4日，即南方同盟撤离两天后，林肯实际上去了南方同盟的首都里士满。这是一个非同寻常的时刻。我实际上不记得斯皮尔伯格电影中有这个。林肯这些年来一直梦想着这一刻，他对他的助手们说，在我看来，我四年来一直做着一个可怕的梦，现在噩梦消失了。他和他的儿子塔迪一起去，这是他最小的男孩。他正在庆祝他的12岁生日。他有腭裂，并患有非常严重的语言障碍。所以对塔迪来说这是一个有点悲伤的故事。他们乘这艘船“河后”号旅行，
with a military escort. And they land in Richmond quite close to the downtown area. And it's an incredible scene because all the former slaves of Richmond, they hear the news that Lincoln has come and they rushed down to the landing place. And the journalists who were there described them shouting, hallelujah, hurrah, hurrah, bless the Lord, praise the Lord. One guy from the Boston Journal said, you know, no written description can capture the emotion of the moment, the shouting and the dancing and the thanksgivings and whatnot
有军事护卫。他们在里士满登陆，离市中心很近。这是一个令人难以置信的场景，因为里士满所有以前的奴隶都听到林肯来了的消息，他们冲向登陆地点。当时在那里的记者形容他们大喊大仑，哈利路亚，万岁，万岁，赞美主，赞美主。波士顿环球报的一个家伙说，你知道，任何书面描述都无法捕捉那一刻的情绪，呐喊和跳舞以及感恩等等
as they greet this bloke, who is their liberator. And Dominic, this guy writing for the Boston Journal, presumably is a war correspondent. And I see in your notes that he's called Charles Coffin. Yes, that's proper nominative to turn. There's a woman there who's shouting, like, thank you, Jesus, that I behold President Lincoln. They all get down and they kneel in front of him. And Lincoln, I mean, the thing about Lincoln is you're always looking for the sort of chink in his armour because it'd be amusing to be revisionist,
当他们迎接这个家伙时，他是他们的解放者。多米尼克，这个为《波士顿环球报》写作的家伙，大概是一个战地记者。我在你的笔记里看到他叫查尔斯·科芬。是的，那是恰当的主格转换。那里有一个女人在喊，谢谢耶稣，我看到了林肯总统。他们都伏下身子跪在他面前。林肯，我的意思是，关于林肯的事情是，你总是在寻找他盔甲上的某种裂缝，因为做修正主义者会很有趣，
but no such chink ever appears. He behaves with such dignity and grace. And he tells him, don't kneel to me, kneel to God only. And that kind of has a resonance because the The Emancipation Statue that then gets built after the war shows a freed slave on his knee in front of Lincoln. And that's been very controversial now. But Lincoln was ahead of the game, really. He wouldn't have approved of that statue. No, he wouldn't actually.
但从来没有出现过这样的裂缝。他表现出如此的尊严和优雅。他告诉他，不要向我跪拜，只向上帝跪拜。这在某种程度上引起了共鸣，因为战后建造的《解放雕像》展示了一个获释的奴隶跪在林肯面前。这现在一直很有争议。但林肯确实走在了时代的前面。他不会赞成那个雕像的。不，他不会的。
It's a really good point. It's a really good point. Anyway, they walk into the city. It's a war zone still. I mean, it's a city with smoldering buildings. There's a pall of smoke. It is incredibly hot. There's a famous moment, another famous moment, again very much
这是一个非常好的观点。这是一个非常好的观点。无论如何，他们步行进入城市。这里仍然是战区。我的意思是，这是一个建筑冒烟的城市。有一团烟雾。天气热得难以置信。有一个著名的时刻，另一个著名的时刻，再次非常大程度上
downs to Lincoln's credit. They pass an old black man in rags and he's kneeling on the ground and he clasps his hands and he says, may the good Lord bless you and keep you safe, master president Lincoln. And Lincoln takes off his hat and he bows to this man and all the watching journalists and whatnot, the entourage are astonished by this. I mean, it's so telling. And Charles Coffin said it was a death shock to chivalry, meaning the the southern hierarchical ideals
归功于林肯。他们路过一个衣衫褴褛的老黑人，他跪在地上，双手合十，说：“愿仁慈的主保佑你，让你平安，总统林肯老爷。”林肯脱下帽子，向这个人鞠躬，所有观看的记者和随从都对此感到惊讶。我的意思是，这太说明问题了。查尔斯·科芬说，这对骑士精神（意指南方的等级制度理想）是一个致命的打击，
and a mortal wound to cast to the idea of caste. I mean, whether it was a mortal wound, I guess you'd say maybe in the very, very long run, but obviously as we know at the time, white supremacy is actually poised to make a bit of a comeback. Anyway.
对等级观念是致命的一击。我的意思是，这是否是致命的一击，我想你会说也许从非常非常长远的角度来看，但显然正如我们所知，当时白人至上主义实际上准备卷土重来。无论如何。
But again, I mean, it kind of, it illustrates the way in which Lincoln in so many ways is, you know, a century and more ahead of conventional thinking. And his grasp of those sort of gestures is unparalleled, I think. Anyway, they reached the White House of the Confederacy. Have you ever been there, Tom?
但再次，我的意思是，它在某种程度上说明了林肯在很多方面，你知道，领先于传统思维一个多世纪甚至更多。他对那种手势的掌握是无与伦比的，我想。无论如何，他们到达了南方同盟的白宫。你去过那里吗，汤姆？
No, I haven't. No. I have. It's quite interesting, actually. It's quite weird because it's a bit like the real White House, but just not as good. Right. Well, I mean, that's the Confederacy for you, isn't it? And he goes and he sits in Jefferson Davis's chair. He's exhausted.
不，我没有。没有。我去过。实际上挺有趣的。挺奇怪的，因为它有点像真正的白宫，只是没那么好。好吧，我的意思是，这就是南方同盟，不是吗？他走进去，坐在杰斐逊·戴维斯的椅子上。他筋疲力尽。
He's very haggard. He's described by captains who are there that he looks, a tired man whose nerves had carried him beyond his strength. He asked for a glass of water, and then they say, would you like to go around all Jefferson Davis's apartments? And he says, no, no, I don't think that'd be right. It's not right to tour another man's home. Amar that? Yeah, exactly. And it ends with him giving this speech in Capital Square in Richmond to a generally black crowd, again freed slaves.
他非常憔悴。在场的船长形容他看起来像一个疲惫的人，他的神经把他推到了体力极限之外。他要了一杯水，然后他们说，你想参观杰斐逊·戴维斯的所有公寓吗？他说，不，不，我觉得这不太合适。参观别人的家是不对的。是吗？对，完全是。最后他在里士满的国会广场向基本上是黑人的群众（同样是获释的奴隶）发表了演讲。
And he says to them, my poor friends, you are free, free as air. You can cast off the name of slave and trample upon it. It will come to you no more. Liberty is your birthright. God gave it to you as he gave it to others. it's a sin that you have been deprived of it for so many years. And then he ends by saying, you know, learn the laws, be good citizens, obey God's commandments, thank him for giving you liberty, for to him you owe all things.
他对他们说：“我可怜的朋友们，你们自由了，像空气一样自由。你们可以抛弃奴隶的名字并践踏它。它将不再找你们麻烦。自由是你们的天赋。上帝赐予了你们，正如他赐予其他人一样。你们被剥夺了这么多年，这是一种罪过。”然后他以这样的话结束：“去学习法律，做优秀的公民，遵守上帝的诫命，感谢他赋予你们自由，因为万物皆归于他。”
It's a very moving stuff. He stays in Richmond for another day, and then he tours the front, and then on the 9th of April, he returns to Washington, D.C. And his mood at this point is a kind of odd mixture. At times, he's very giddy almost with happiness, but then he can be. be very melancholy. So when they're sailing home on the River Queen, he actually reads a soliloquy from Macbeth to his, to his companions. Hard to imagine the current president doing that, I think. But it's so interesting, isn't it? Because it's, what is it, in your notes
这是非常感人的东西。他在里士满多呆了一天，然后参观了前线，然后在4月9日，他返回了华盛顿特区。他此时的心情是一种奇怪的混合。有时他几乎因幸福而头晕目眩，但有时他又会非常忧郁。所以当他们乘“河后”号船回家时，他实际上向他的同伴们朗读了《麦克白》中的独白。很难想象现任总统会这样做，我想。但这不是很趣吗，因为它是什么，在你的笔记里
you say, it's the syllable queen Macbeth delivers after he's murdered Duncan. Yeah. So much blood. And that must be expressive of a sense of guilt. I mean, Macbeth is consumed by guilt. It's so interesting he would choose that speech. Because Macbeth is actually saying at one point, I'm so troubled by guilt that I envy Duncan, who I've killed, who is now sleeping under the sleep of the just. And I think Lincoln absolutely feels that. You know, he's on this tour of the front, he's said again and again how much he regrets the bloodshed and the killing. You know, he doesn't glory in victory. But it's more than that, isn't it? Surely it's a sense of, I mean, maybe unrealised even by himself, of worry whether he has been the
你说，这是麦克白在谋杀邓肯后发表的独白。是的。如此多的血。这一定表达了一种负罪感。我的意思是，麦克白被罪恶感吞噬了。他选择这段演讲真是太有趣了。因为麦克白实际上在某个时刻说，我被罪恶感困扰，以至于我嫉妒我杀死的邓肯，他现在正安睡在正义者的睡眠中。我想林肯绝对有这种感觉。你知道，他在前线巡视，一次又一次地表示他多么后悔流血和杀戮。你知道，他并不为胜利而感到荣耀。但这不仅如此，对吧？当然这是一种感觉，我的意思是，也许甚至连他自己都没有意识到，担心他是否一直是
the tyrant of Confederate invective, whether he has spilled the blood of Americans on the altar of his presidency? I don't know. No, I think you're right, Tom. I think everything we know about Lincoln suggests that he's a man who, while ultimately a very effective politician,
南方同盟抨击中的暴君，他是否在自己总统职位的祭坛上洒下了美国人的血？我不知道。不，我想你是对的，汤姆。我想我们对林肯的了解都表明他是一个这样的人：虽然最终是一个非常高效的政治家，
very firm, decisive, all of those things, that he is an intensely reflective person. And there is also a kind of humility to him. I mean, I don't want to turn into a kind of Lincoln, hagiography, but he is one of those characters in history that you kind of look for an opportunity to be revisionist and actually there isn't really one. Now, the one thing I will say is the thing about Macbeth, I think there is a fatalism to Lincoln at this point. He has said many times to people, I wonder if I will ever see the end of the war, whether I will live to
非常坚定、果断，所有这些，但他是一个极其内省的人。他身上也有某种谦逊。我的意思是，我不想变成某种林肯圣徒传，但他是历史上的那些人物之一，你有时会寻找机会去做修正主义者，但实际上并没有这样一个机会。现在，我要说的一件事是关于麦克白的事，我认为林肯此时有一种宿命论。他多次对人们说，我不知道我是否能看到战争的结束，我是否能活到
see the end of it. He has dreams of his potential murder, doesn't he? Exactly so. Exactly. He said to Harriet Beecher Stowe, however it ends, I have the impression that I shan't last long after it is over. And actually, at this point, when he's reading that speech from Macbeth, it is the 9th of April and he has only five days to live. But actually, while he's on the boat, there is a very, very dramatic development. Elsewhere in Virginia, at Appomattox Courthouse, Robert E. Lee's army has been cornered and trapped. They failed to break through the Union lines.
看到它的结局。他梦到自己可能被暗杀，对吧？完全正确。千真万确。他对哈丽特·比彻·斯托说，无论结局如何，我有一种感觉，这一切结束后，我活不了多久了。而实际上，此时当他正在朗读《麦克白》中的那段台词时，已经是4月9日了，他只剩下五天可活。但实际上，就在他在船上时，发生了一个非常非常戏剧性的进展。在弗吉尼亚州的其他地方，在阿波马托克斯法院，罗伯特·E·李的军队已经被包围并陷入绝境。他们未能突破联邦军队的防线。
And that afternoon, in a place called the McLean Farmhouse, Lee signs the instrument of surrender. It's a scene we described before, I think, in our Custer series. Yeah, because he was there, wasn't he? Yeah. Eli Parker, who was General Grant's adjutant, wrote out the document. And when Lee found out that this bloke was a Seneca Indian, he said, oh, it's good to have one real American here. And an absolute Hollywood style, Parker said, sir, we're all Americans. And everyone clasped their hand over the heart and burst into patriotic tears. Everybody cries, but nobody more than tabby watching that in the film version, I think. Anyway, the next day, the 10th, Lincoln is back in Washington. He's actually in great form. And his advisors say, you know, they'd never seen
那天下午，在一个叫麦克林农庄的地方，李将军签署了投降书。我想，这是我们在卡斯特系列中曾描述过的场景。是的，因为他在场，不是吗？是的。作为格兰特将军副官的伊利·帕克起草了这份文件。当李发现这家伙是个塞内卡印第安人时，他说，哦，这里能有一个真正的美国人真好。具有绝对的好莱坞风格的是，帕克说，先生，我们全都是美国人。每个人都把手放在胸前，热泪盈眶。每个人都在哭，但我猜，看电影版的塔比哭得比谁都厉害。不管怎样，第二天，即10日，林肯回到了华盛顿。他的状态其实非常好。他的顾问们说，你知道，他们从未见过
him so happy because he's heard the news. Because he's fun, isn't he as well? He's great sense of humour. So when he's, when he's on a jig, he's all in. Exactly. He's a very, he's an up and down person, I think it's fair to say. When he's melancholy, he's very melancholy and when he's jolly, he's very jolly. And of course, he's got big challenges now. Now they really have to make up their mind. What do they do with the rebel states? Now, at the time, lots of people say, why don't you give a speech? Go on everyone wants a speech. But he said, no, no, I need a day to think about it. So it's not until the next day, the 11th of April, that evening, with a huge crowd waiting outside the White House that he gives this speech. And very unusually, and this is a
他这么高兴，因为他听到了消息。因为他很有趣，不是吗？他很有幽默感。所以当他情绪高涨时，他整个人都投入进去了。完全正确。他是一个情绪起伏很大的人，我觉得这样说很公道。当他忧郁时，他非常忧郁；当他快乐时，他非常快乐。当然，他现在面临着巨大的挑战。现在他们必须下定决心了。他们该拿叛乱各州怎么办？当时，很多人说，你为什么不发表一篇演讲呢？去吧，每个人都想听演讲。但他说，不，不，我需要一天时间考虑一下。所以直到第二天，即4月11日那天傍晚，白宫外聚集了庞大的群众，他才发表了这篇演讲。非常罕见的是，这标志着
sign, I think, of the political pressure, he reads from a text. He doesn't deliver his remarks extemporary. Because he needs every word to be finally valued and graded. He says, I'm going to talk about reconstruction, and sometimes I'm betrayed into saying things that other people don't like. And he doesn't talk really at all about, again, no triumphalism. He says, I would like us to welcome back the rebel states as though they were never out of the union. In other words, we're like loving parents and we're welcoming the errant child back into the family. Or the prodigal son, because I imagine that, you know, the language of the New Testament is saturating his prose. But now comes the kicker. For the very first time in public, Lincoln says,
我认为，这是政治压力的一个信号，他是照着稿子念的。他没有即兴发表演讲。因为他需要让每一个字都经过最终的权衡和打分。他说，我要谈谈重建，有时我会不经意地说出一些别人不喜欢的话。他几乎完全没有谈到任何凯旋主义。他说，我希望我们重新欢迎叛乱各州回来，就像他们从未离开过联邦一样。换句话说，我们就像慈爱的父母，正迎回迷途知返的孩子。或者说像浪子回头，因为我想，你知道，新约圣经的语言充斥着他的散文。但接下来才是重头戏。林肯破天荒第一次在公开场合表示，
I think it is time to give the vote to some of our black fellow citizens. He says, I would myself prefer that it were now conferred on the very intelligent and on those who serve our cause as soldiers. Now, that may sound like only a small move, but that's how Lincoln always works. He works with the sort of thin end of the wedge. He's a gradualist, he's always very, exactly what he did with emancipation. He moves slowly but steadily towards a more radical position. This is a massive, massive moment.
我认为是时候把投票权赋予我们的一些黑人同胞了。他说，我个人更倾向于现在就赋予那些非常聪明的人，以及那些曾作为士兵为我们的事业服务过的人。这听起来可能只是一小步，但林肯一向是这样办事的。他采用的是一种渐进的方式。他是个渐进主义者，总是非常——这正是他在废奴问题上所做的。他缓慢但坚定地朝着更激进的立场迈进。这是一个无比重大的时刻。
And for one listener in the crowd in particular, these words are like an electric shock or something. And this bloke is a 26-year-old actor. And when he hears Lincoln say these words, he turns to the man next to him in the crowd, and he says, that means citizenship. Now, by God, I'll put him through.
对于人群中的某一位听众来说，这些话就像是一记电击或是别的什么。这家伙是一个26岁的演员。当他听到林肯说出这些话时，他转向人群中身旁的一个人，说道，这意味着公民身份。现在，凭上帝起誓，我一定要干掉他。
That is the last speech he will ever make. And as we'll find out after the break, John Wilkes Booth means every word. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to The Restless History. And Dominic, just before the break, you mentioned a man in the crowd listening to Lincoln talk about giving black Americans the vote. And this was a young actor called John Wilkes Booth. Who is he? And does he? And does he? have a link to a famous assassin of Julius Caesar? He does indeed. He's born in Maryland in May 1838. He's 26 years old. He is the son of a Shakespearean actor from London
那是他发表的有生以来最后一次演讲。正如我们在中场休息后会发现的那样，约翰·威尔克斯·布斯说到做到。大家好。欢迎回到《不安分的历史》。多米尼克，就在中场休息前，你提到人群中有一个人在听林肯谈论给予美国黑人投票权。而这是一个名叫约翰·威尔克斯·布斯的年轻演员。他是谁？他跟朱利叶斯·塞撒著名的刺客有什么联系吗？他确实有。他于1838年5月出生在马里兰州。他今年26岁。他是一个来自伦敦的莎士比亚演员的儿子，
called Junius Brutus Booth. And this bloke Booth's mistress, Mary Ann Holmes. And they had moved to America 17 years earlier. Now Junius, Junius Brutus Booth was already married to somebody else. So John Wilkes, who is named after the John Wilkes, right? John Wilkes is a Whig MP in Georgian London. Marcus Junius Brutus, of course, is the famous assassin of Julius Caesar. Both of them, obviously, are radicals, people committed to the overthrow of tyranny. So this presumably is a family tradition. Totally. I mean, I think John Wilkes Booth grows up with this sort of nominative determinism hanging over him. Now, he's illegitimate because his parents aren't married, right? His father was married to somebody else. Now, actually, when he was 13, his parents did get
名叫朱尼厄斯·布鲁图斯·布斯。这个家伙布斯的情妇是玛丽·安·霍姆斯。他们在17岁前就搬到了美国。现在朱尼厄斯，朱尼厄斯·布鲁图斯·布斯其实已经跟别人结过婚了。所以约翰·威尔克斯，他因约翰·威尔克斯而得名，对吧？约翰·威尔克斯是乔治时代伦敦的一名辉格党议员。而马库斯·朱尼厄斯·布鲁图斯，当然就是朱利叶斯·恺撒著名的刺客。很明显，他们两个都是激进分子，是致力于推翻暴政的人。所以这大概是一个家族传统。完全是。我的意思是，我认为约翰·威尔克斯·布斯伴随着这种宿命论长大，这种魔咒一直笼罩着他。现在，他是个私生子，因为他的父母没有结婚，对吧？他的父亲跟别人结过婚。实际上，当他13岁时，他的父母确实结了婚，但对他来说已经有点太晚了。他的传记作家通常认为，这种耻辱感和羞耻感是他巨大的驱动力。就像他总是深深地感到，他的父母在生下他时其实并没有结婚。现在，他是一个非常健美、英俊的家伙，有着男主角的长相。他在马里兰州上了寄宿学校。他沉浸在古典文学中。所以，如果他父亲的名字还不够的话，他成长过程中一直在阅读西塞罗、塔西陀以及所有这类作品。也就是说，这些罗马作家本质上是反对恺撒暴政的。完全正确。他非常喜欢这一切。绝对狂热。现在，他父亲是个演员。他的哥哥埃德温是个演员，当他17岁时，他自己也开始在巴尔的摩的舞台上成为一名演员，那是1850年。
married, but it's kind of too late for him. And the stigma and the shame of this, his biographers often think, are massive drivers for him. Like, he always feels this very keenly that his parents weren't actually married when they had him. Now, he's a very athletic, handsome bloke with kind of leading man looks. He went to boarding school in Maryland. He's steeped in the classic. So if his father's name wasn't enough, he kind of grows up reading Cicero and Tacitus and all this sort of stuff. So Roman authors who are essentially opposed to the tyranny of the Caesars. Exactly. He loves all this. Absolutely loves it. Now, his father was an actor. His older brother, Edwin was an actor, and when he was 17 years old, he starts out as an actor himself on the stage in Baltimore, 1850.
每个人都说哥哥埃德温是一个演技更加细腻、更加精确的演员。但约翰·威尔克斯，他更有活力、更喧闹、更令人兴奋，有点像布赖恩·布莱斯德。有点像，是的。他有点像个爱演过头的演员，但却是个有趣的活宝。他是一个极度抢戏的人，而且他会做——他专门擅长跳跃。我不知道莎士比亚独白剧里有多少机会能让人做一点点小跳跃、翻筋斗之类的动作。我的意思是，
Everybody always said that Edwin, the older brother, was a kind of more nuanced actor, more precise. But John Wilkes, he's more vital, he's boisterous, he's exciting, he's kind of Brian Blessed. A little bit, yeah. He's a bit of a ham, but he's a fun ham. And he's a huge scene stealer, and he will do, he specialises in leaps. I don't know how much opportunities there isn't Shakespearean soliloquist to do a little, little, leap or caper or something. I mean,
在舞台上跳跃将成为后来故事的一个特色，不是吗？正是如此。他做这些跳跃，基本上观众席上的女性看到他做这种杂技动作时都会陷入疯狂的兴奋。他收到了来自女性的大量粉丝信件。在内战前夕，也就是1860、1861年，
leaping across a stage will be a feature of the story later on, won't it? Exactly. And he does these leaps and basically the women in the audience go mad with excitement when he does these kind of acrobatics. And he gets loads of fan mail from women. And on the eve of the Civil War, so 1860, 61,
他刚刚二十出头。他真的被视为一个——我的意思是，他经常被形容为一个失败的演员或零工演员。他其实是个相当大的明星，我一直在琢磨这个，看你能不能给个类比，
he's in his very early 20s. And he is really seen as a, I mean, he's often described actually as a failed actor or jobbing actor. he's quite a big star I was wondering about this and whether you could give an analogy
用当今的明星体系来衡量——我的意思是，他是蒂莫西·柴勒梅德吗？他是《阿彻一家》里的一个小配角吗？他在这个光谱的什么位置呢？嗯，蒂莫西·柴勒梅德是一个非常大的明星。
in today's star system I mean is he Timothy Shalame is he a minor part on the archers I mean where is he on the spectrum well Timothy Shalame is a very big star
我不知道他是不是有那么大牌，但他绝对比一个龙套角色要大，他大概会是某种HBO电视剧的主演，那种级别。
I don't know whether he's quite that big but he's definitely bigger than a bit part he'd be a lead on a kind of HBO TV series perhaps that level
我会说，他会是——他会是《古战场传奇》的主演。我以前一直相信这种说法，即他是一个微不足道的、受挫的演员，从来接不到任何工作之类的。而意识到其实他一直在出演一部HBO剧集，这让事情有了完全不同的转折。是的。他可能是美国历史上最著名的刺客，我的意思是，他在行凶之前就已经很有名了。没错。哦，他绝对很有名。他演过理查三世。他演过罗密欧。他演过哈姆雷特。
I'd say he would he would be the lead in Outlander. I had always brought into this thing that he was a minor, frustrated actor who never got any jobs or anything. And to realise that actually he's been starring in an HBO series puts a completely different spin on it. Yeah. He is probably the most famous assassin in American history, by which I mean, he's got a profile before he commits the murder. Right. Oh, he's totally got a profile. He's played Richard III. He's paid Romeo. He's played Hamlet.
他演过布鲁图斯。他演过马克·安东尼。因为人们经常说刺客都是失败者，不是吗？我的意思是，我们在做肯尼迪系列时讨论过这个。但在这种情况下，并非如此。他是一个习惯于站在舞台上的人。正如我们将看到的，这次刺杀将看到他跳上一座舞台。没错。尽管在他生活的某些方面，他确实强烈地觉得自己是个失败者。
He's played Brutus. He's played Mark Anthony. Because it is often said that assassins are losers, isn't it? I mean, we talked about this when we did the JFK series. But in this case, it's not true. He is someone who is used to being on the stage. And as we will see, the assassination will see him jump onto a stage. Exactly. Although there are aspects of his life in which he does feel himself very strongly to be a loser.
所以从某种意义上说，他是个失败者。但你是对的，在职业上，他过得相当不错。有趣的是，他的大本营在北方和边境各州，他在华盛顿、纽约和费城等地做过大量演出。1863年11月，汤姆，这就是一个很好的例子，说明他是一个被许多名人关注的明星。他扮演一个阴险古希腊雕塑家。这是一部可悲地没有真正经受住时间考验的戏剧，它在剧目中被称为《大理石心》。剧本现在还在吗？我确信还在。
So he is a loser in a sense. But you're right, professionally, he's had quite a good run. Now, interestingly, his heartland is the north and the border states, and he did loads of shows in Washington, in New York and Philadelphia and so on. In November 1863, here's a good example, Tom, of how he's a star watched by very famous people. He plays a villainous ancient Greek sculptor. Get a play that sadly not really endured, it's in the repertoire called The Marble Heart. Is it still around the script? I'm sure it is.
我敢打赌你在某处能找到它。你想演它。他演出的剧院名叫华盛顿10街的福特剧院，观众席的包厢里坐着亚伯拉罕·林肯。在不同的时刻，布斯在不跳跃的时候，会发表这些带有威胁性的台词、反派的台词，而他是对着总统包厢说的。林肯实际上对她的朋友说，他看着我的眼神真的很犀利，不是吗？这绝非偶然，因为布斯对林肯痛恨至极。我刚才说过他出生在马里兰州。从危机一开始，布斯就强烈认同南方。
I bet you can find it somewhere. you want to play it. The theatre he plays at is called Ford's Theatre on 10th Street in Washington and in the audience in the box is Abraham Lincoln. And at various points Booth is delivering when he's not leaping, he's delivering these menacing line, villainous lines and he aims them at the presidential box. And Lincoln actually says to her friend, he does look pretty sharp at me, doesn't he? Now this is no accident because Booth absolutely loathes Lincoln. I said he was born in Maryland. From the beginning of the crisis, both identified very strongly with the South.
马里兰州是一个蓄奴州，很多人强烈支持南部邦联，但它没有脱离联邦。所以它没有加入南部邦联各州。部分原因是联邦军队立即实施了军事管制。这也是因为林肯暂停了人身保护令。马里兰州在战略上至关重要。如果你失去了它，你就会失去华盛顿。所以联邦守住它，真的是非常非常重要。
Maryland was a slave state where a lot of people strongly supported the Confederacy, but it didn't break away from the Union. So it didn't join the Confederate states. That's partly because the Union troops right away imposed martial law. It's also because Lincoln suspended habeas corpus. Maryland is strategically vital. If you lost that, you would lose Washington. So the Union keeping, it was really, really important.
布斯对此感受极其深刻。他之所以对这一点感受如此深刻、恨马里兰州是联邦一部分的原因之一，是因为他是个彻头彻尾的种族主义者。1860年危机真正爆发时，他其实已经起草了一份演讲稿。他计划在费城发表，但他从未付诸行动。在这篇演讲中，他说，你知道，奴隶制太棒了。他说，我走过南方。我看到奴隶们有多么快乐。我看到过黑人被鞭打，
Now, Booth feels this very keenly. And one reason he feels this very keenly, he hates the fact that Maryland is part of the union is because he is so racist. He had actually drafted a speech in 1860 when the crisis was really blowing up. And he planned to give it in Philadelphia, but he never did. And in this speech, he said, you know, slavery is brilliant. He said, I've been through the South. I've seen how happy the slaves are. I have seen black people whipped,
但那只是因为他们罪有应得，而且从来没有超过他们应得的程度。他对废奴主义者说，我称他们为叛徒。叛国罪应该被彻底铲除。我对这样的人恨之入骨。我真希望把他们抓在手里。如果我有权力粉碎他们，
but only when they really deserved it, and never as much as they deserved. And he says of abolitionists, I call them traitors. Treason should be stamped to death. So deep is my hatred for such men. I wish I had them in my grasp. And if I had the power to crush them,
我会把他们碾成粉末。所以他是非常反对觉醒文化病毒的。他非常反对觉醒文化病毒，这样说很公道。现在，你完全可能会说，得了吧，老兄。我的意思是，如果你真的那么恨它，你为什么不直接去为南部邦联作战呢？问得好。他的回答是什么？他答应过他母亲不会去。所以他不仅是个种族主义者，还是个种族主义妈宝男。
I would grind them into dust. So he's very against the woke mind virus. He's very much against the woke mind virus, it's fair to say. Now, you might well say, come on, mate. I mean, if you really hate it that much, why don't you actually go and fight for the Confederacy? Good point. What's his answer? He's promised his mother that he wouldn't. So not only is he racist, but he's a racist mummy's boy.
是的，他是个懦弱的种族主义者。最糟糕的那种懦夫和最糟糕的那种种族主义者，我觉得这样说很公道。不，最糟糕的种族主义者是种族主义体育老师，我们对此达成过共识。我想我们是达成过，是的。是的，但这是第二种。体育老师和懦夫，这就是其中的复仇图表，我想。不管怎样，他是一个极其严重的妈宝男，带着一种稍微有点诡异的方式，这就是为什么尽管他很受女士们的欢迎，但他从未结婚，也从未——你知道，他从未真正安定下来。但随着战争的进行，他对此感到内疚。随着战争的进行，
Yeah, he's a cowardly racist. The worst kind of coward and the worst kind of racist, I think it's fair to say. No, the worst kind of racist is racist P.E teachers, we agreed on that. I think we did, yeah. Yeah, but this is the second. Pea teachers and cowards is the revenge diagram there, I wonder. Anyway, he is such a massive mummy's boy in a really slightly weird way, which is why despite being very popular with the ladies, he's never got married and never, you know, he's never really settled down. But as the war goes on, he feels guilty about this. As the war goes
人们对他说，你知道的，我们别再谈论战争了。别再喋喋不休地说你有多爱南部邦联了。如果你那么喜欢它，就去为它而战吧。甚至他的姐姐也这么说。如果你那么爱南方，为什么不去为它而战呢？每一个配得上这个名字的马里兰人都在为它的战事奋斗。在1864年末的某个时候，他对母亲说，我开始觉得自己是个懦夫，并鄙视自己的存在。所以这段时间他还在演戏吗？他演着的。他做得相当不错。他其实真的很用心地在演相当大的角色，并且获得了大量的赞誉之类。但他很不开心。他的家族有精神不稳定的历史。他的父亲是个严重的虐妻狂。他酗白兰地。他牛饮着白兰地，而且他睡不着觉。
on, people say to him, you know, we'll stop talking about the war. Stop going on about how much you love the Confederacy. And if you like it that much, go and fight for it. Even his sister says this. Why not go and fight for her if you love the South so much? Every Marylander worthy of the name is fighting her battles. And at one point in late 1864, he says to his mum, I've begun to deem myself a coward and to despise my own existence. So all this time he's still doing his plays, is he? He isn't. He's doing quite well. He actually genuinely is playing quite big parts and he's getting a lot of acclaim and stuff. But he's unhappy. His family had a history of mental instability. His father was a massive wife-beater. He's drinking loads. His necking loads of brandy and he can't
我想这很大程度上其实是因为他对战争感到内疚，而且因为来自前线的消息，在他看来是如此糟糕。所以基本上南方输掉的每一场战役，他就会接着再喝掉一加仑左右的白兰地。他将所有的愤怒和怨恨都聚焦在了林肯身上。所以一个理发师事后说，基本上，每当布斯出现要求剃须时，大家都会叹气并翻白眼，因为基本上在接下来的10分钟里，他要向他们发表一段关于林肯有多糟糕的独白。他对他的姐姐说，那个男人的外表、他的家世、他粗俗低级的人。
sleep. And I think a lot of this is actually because he feels so guilty about the war and because the news from the front is, as he perceives it, so bad. So basically every battle the South lose, he then drinks like another gallon of brandy or something. And he focuses all of this rage and resentment on the figure of Lincoln. So a barber said afterwards, basically, whenever Booth turned up for a shave, everyone would kind of sigh and roll their eyes because basically for the next 10 minutes, he's going to treat them to a monologue about how terrible Lincoln is. He said to his sister, that man's appearance, his pedigree, his coarse, low jokes.
和趣闻。他庸俗的比喻和他的政策是他所坐位置的耻辱。对林肯那些低级庸俗笑话的讨论还不够，我想。我的意思是，有趣的是，显然没有任何审查的概念，你可以在一场可怕内战的深渊中辱骂总统，而人们只是稍微翻个白眼。所以任何将林肯视为暴君的概念显然都是疯狂的。嗯，正如我们将看到的，你知道，一些北方的报纸对亚伯拉罕·林肯的攻击极其凶猛，言辞极其恶毒。所以，实际上这也给我们带来了一个重要观点。布斯喜欢历史类比。
and anecdotes. His vulgar similes and his policy are a disgrace to the seat he holds. Not enough chat about Lincoln's low vulgar jokes, I think. I mean, it is interesting that there is clearly no notion of any censorship going on, that you can badmouth the president in the depths of a terrible civil war, and people just slightly roll their eyes. So any notion of Lincoln as a tyrant is clearly mad. Well, as we will see, you know, some northern newspapers are absolutely ferocious and they're invective against Abraham Lincoln. So, and actually this brings us to an important point. Booth loves a historical analogy.
我们也喜欢。所以这是一个令人不安的公平对比。公平地说，汤姆，那浮夸的演技。有很多，有很多——我本来不想深入探讨相似之处，但它们实在太明显了。首先，他将林肯视为美利坚的拿破仑，而且他绝对不是在善意地指代这一点。所以他在1864年对他的姐姐说。林肯通过抢劫、掠夺、屠杀和收买的军队进行统治。
So do we. So that is an unsettling point of comparison. To be fair, Tom, the hammy acting. There's a lot of, there's a lot of, I didn't want to go into the parallels, but they're pretty, they're pretty overwhelming. First of all, he sees Lincoln as an American Napoleon, and he does not mean that kindly. So he says to his sister in 1864. Lincoln rules by robbery, rapine, slaughter and bought armies.
他是在一次伟大的行动中成为波拿巴的，那就是推翻这个盲目的共和国并让自己成为国王。多米尼克，请问，世界历史上还有没有另一个在共和国中被同胞指控企图自立为王的人物？有的，这会让Reddit上的那个家伙高兴的。这就是朱利叶斯·恺撒。太棒了。万岁。所以布斯在下定决心要做这件恶劣的事时，确实写了一封信。他写了一封信给报纸发表，但从未被印刷。
He is bone apart in one great move that is by overturning this blind republic and making himself a king. And Dominic, can I ask, is there another figure from world history who is accused by his fellow citizens in a republic of trying to make himself a king? There is, and this will please that bloke on the Reddit. It's Julius Caesar. Brilliant. Array. So Booth actually writes a letter when he's made up his mind to do this dastly deed. He writes a letter to the newspapers for publication which has never printed.
他说，明确地说，林肯就像威胁人民自由的恺撒，而我则像起身杀死他的布鲁图斯。现在，迈克尔·伯林盖姆在他那本厚重的林肯著作中，有一个非常有趣的部分，讲到这在当时是一个多么受欢迎的类比。这依然是一个受欢迎的类比。我想我们讨论过，在一个以罗马共和国为蓝本的共和国里，
And he says, specifically says, Lincoln is like Caesar who menaced the liberties of the people, and I am like Brutus, who arose and slew him. Now, Michael Burlingame, in his enormous Lincoln book, has a really interesting section about what a popular analogy this is at the time. It's still a popular analogy. I think we've talked about this, that in a republic that is modelled on the Roman Republic,
每个人都绝对倾向于将任何总统人物视为潜在的恺撒。尽管，在那个所有的意见塑造者、政治家之流都受过如此古典教育的时代，这种倾向肯定要强烈得多？当然，而且这也是在内战期间，恺撒正是通过内战上台的。现在，南方的报纸经常使用这个平行对比。所以你问，南方人在呼唤刺杀林肯吗？《里士满快报》说，我引述一下，抽象意义上的刺杀是一桩可怕的罪行，但杀死一个暴君，其性质并不比
everyone is absolutely prone to see any presidential figure as potentially a Caesar. Although, surely much more so at a time when all the opinion form as politicians and whatnot have had such a classical education. Of course, and also in a civil war, which is how Caesar comes to power. Now, in the Southern newspapers often use this parallel. So you asked, a Southerners calling for Lincoln's assassination? The Richmond Dispatch said, and I quote, assassination in the abstract is a horrid crime, but to slay a tyrant is no more assassination than
战争是谋杀更像是刺杀。谁把布鲁图斯称为刺客？哪个北方佬曾谴责把查理一世送上断头台的圆颅党人？所以不仅是恺撒，他还是查理一世。迈克尔·伯林盖姆指出，在北方也是如此，这就是你关于审查制度的观点，汤姆。林肯的批评者经常把他与朱利叶斯·恺撒作比较。所以在1863年5月，这些人是民主党人，以及一些激进的共和党人，他们认为林肯太像一个中间派老爹了。他们说他是暴君，在集权等等。所以在1863年5月，在纽约的一所名为库珀联盟的学院里，一名发言人在公开场合说，让我们提醒林肯，恺撒有他的布鲁图斯，查理一世有他的克伦威尔。
war is murder. Who speaks of Brutus as an assassin? What Yankee ever condemned the roundhead crew who brought Charles I to the block? So it's not just Caesar, he's Charles I. Michael Burlingame points out that in the north as well, and this is your point about censorship, Tom. Lincoln's critics often compare him with Julius Caesar. So in May 1863, so these are Democrats, and some radical Republicans, actually, who think that Lincoln is too much of a centrist's dad. They say he's a tyrant and he's piling up power and whatnot. So in May 1863, at a New York College called the Cooper Union, a speaker said in public, let us remind Lincoln that Caesar had his Brutus and Charles I, the first, his Cromwell.
让我们也提醒当代的乔治三世，他可能也会有他的克伦威尔或他的布鲁图斯。多米尼克，只有两个问题。第一个问题，我脑海深处隐约有个印象。我想我读过一篇关于历史上生物恐怖主义的文章。有个家伙给林肯寄了一堆衣服，他试图用黄热病之类的病毒感染这些衣服。对。他的名字叫卢克·P·布莱克本医生。他来自肯塔基州。
Let us also remind George III of the present day that he too may have his Cromwell or his Brutus. Dominic, just two questions. The first, I have lurking in the back of my mind. I think I read an article about bioterrorism through history. There was some guy who sent Lincoln a load of clothes that he tried to infect with yellow fever or something. Yeah. His name was Dr. Luke P. Blackburn. And he was from Kentucky.
他是南方邦联的特工。我在笑是因为其实我刚刚谷歌了一下。所以我其实并不是真的知道这个。他，是的，他打算分发沾有黄热病病毒的感染衣物，而且，呃，稍微有点奇怪的是，那是百慕大人们穿过的、弄脏的——是弄脏的床上用品，我想那是很不卫生的，而且显然这行不通，因为黄热病是通过蚊子传播的。他进行了一次非常漫长的旅行，他不得不穿过加拿大——所以带着他那弄脏的床单通过了多个海关检查员。哇，好吧。所以那是你的第一个问题。你的第二个问题是什么？我的第二个问题是林肯有什么安保措施？所以想必此时并没有什么国家安全局之类的机构。没有很多穿西装戴墨镜的人。嗯，实际上，我们会谈到这一点的，汤姆。我很高兴地说。他几乎没有任何安保措施。他不需要安保。他不喜欢保镖。这不是联邦提供的。没有。所以他基本上得为自己提供安保。差不多吧。完全正确。差不多是这样。是的。现在，你问到了安保。约翰·威尔克斯·布斯的第一个想法其实是绑架林肯，而不是杀死他。
He was a confederate agent. I'm laughing because actually, I've just Googled it. So I don't actually really know this. he uh yes he was going to distribute infected clothing with yellow fever and um slightly slightly weirdly it's it's the soiled the soiled what it was the soiled bedding of people from bermuda i think that's unpleasant and apparently it wouldn't have worked because yellow fever spreads um via mosquitoes he went on a very long journey he had to go through through canada so multiple customs
到1864年，布斯制定了这个计划，要从华盛顿郊外的夏日别墅绑架林肯。现在，这个计划的细节有点不太清楚，但似乎发生的情况是，布斯认为他可以绑架林肯，并用他来交换南方邦联的战俘。如果你绑架了其中一个交战方的领袖，只为了把他交出去换战俘，这简直是疯狂的浪费。仅仅为了换取战俘就把他交出去，我觉得这太疯狂了。一些历史学家认为这实际上是一个更广泛的南部邦联阴谋的一部分。南方邦联在华盛顿有很多间谍和四处游荡的秘密特工。其中一人名叫约翰·萨拉特，他绝对为南方邦联特勤局工作过。他的母亲玛丽·萨拉特——我们一会儿会谈到她。
inspectors with his soiled bed linen. Wow, well. So that was your first question. What was your second? My second question is what kind of security does Lincoln have? So presumably there isn't a kind of national security service at this point. There aren't loads of people in suits with dark glasses. Well, actually, we will get on to this, Tom. I'm delighted to say. He has virtually no security at all. He doesn't want security. He doesn't like bodyguards. It's not federally provided. No. So he has to basically provide it for himself. Pretty much. Exactly. Pretty much. Yeah. Now, you asked about security. John Wilkes Booth's first idea is actually to kidnap Lincoln, not to kill him.
她在华盛顿经营一家寄宿公寓，那是南方邦联特工的安全屋。而布斯似乎与这些人有联系。他有个计划，打算在路上绑架林肯，然后把他带走囚禁起来。直到1865年3月，他身边还有一群随从，他一直在跟他们滔滔不绝地谈论这个绑架计划，但这并没有真正付诸实施。有一天他们确实去了，但林肯没有露面。
By 1864, Booth has developed this plan to kidnap Lincoln from his summer cottage outside Washington. Now, the details of this plan are a little bit unclear, but what seems to have happened is Booth thought he could kidnap Lincoln and exchange him for Confederate prisoners of war. That seems a mad waste if you've kidnapped the leader of the one of the combatants. Just to hand him over in exchange from prisoners of war, I think is demented. Some historians think this is actually part of a wider Confederate conspiracy. The Confederates had a lot of spies in Washington and secret agents hanging around. One of them is a man called John Surratt, who definitely worked for the Confederate Secret Service. And his mother, Mary Surat, will come on to her.
所以他们到底能不能成功，谁知道呢。接着在1865年4月初，布斯听到了里士满陷落以及罗伯特·E·李投降的消息。他彻底崩溃了。我想这就是他萌生杀死林肯而非绑架他的想法的时刻。这里还有另一个因素。你问他是不是个失败者。毫无疑问的是，约翰·威尔克斯·布斯觉得自己是个失败者，并且被对名声的渴望所驱动。他一次又一次地对朋友说，一个人可以通过杀死林肯来让自己永垂不朽。他说，我想做一些能让我被后世永远铭记的事情。所以问题是，他会得到这个机会吗？我们待会儿会说到。现在，回到林肯。
She ran a boarding house in Washington, which was a safe house for Confederate agents. And Booth seems to have been connected with these people. And he has this scheme that they're going to kidnap Lincoln on the road, then take him off into captivity. And as late as March 1865, he's got a group of kind of hangers on and he's chatting to them all the time about this kidnap scheme, but it doesn't really come to anything. There's one day when they do actually go, but Lincoln doesn't turn up.
林肯在4月11日发表了那篇演讲。但在两天后的4月13日，他开始头痛得厉害。他本来打算和玛丽坐马车去看看华盛顿各处为庆祝胜利而亮起的燃气照明。他去不了。所以他们让尤利西斯·S·格兰特代劳。玛丽则去了。结果呢？这次出行简直是一场灾难。人群为格兰特欢呼并高喊他的名字。玛丽·林肯基本上愤怒极了。甚至在某个时刻，她要求马车夫停下来让她下车，因为她再也受不了人们高喊格兰特的名字而不是她丈夫的名字了。我挺喜欢她的。我开始尊重她了。我觉得她很糟糕。
So whether they could have pulled us off, who knows. Then in early April 1865, Booth hears the news of the fall of Richmond and then of Robert E. Lee's surrender. And he is absolutely crushed. And I think this is the point when he comes up with the idea of killing Lincoln rather than kidnapping him. And there's another element to this. You asked if he was a loser. What is undoubtedly true is that John Wilkes Booth feels himself to be a failure and is motivated by a thirst for fame. He says to friends again and again, a man could immortalize himself by killing Lincoln. He says, I want to do something that will mean that I'm remembered for all time. So the question is, will he get the chance? And we'll come to that. Now, back to Lincoln.
我的意思是，除了我在乔治·桑德斯的小说里读到的之外，我对她一无所知。她让我更有同情心了。好吧，好吧。所以第二天是耶稣受难日，即4月14日。林肯在耶稣受难日被杀。是的。所以这个具有基督般特质的人在耶稣受难日被杀。编都编不出来。所以那天早上，他生命的最后一个早晨，林肯召开了一次内阁会议，格兰特将军也出席了。他们再次谈论重建。他说摆在我们面前的伟大问题，我们必须尽快开始行动。但他说，我不会对南方采取强硬态度。如果我们期望实现和谐与统一，我们就必须消灭我们的怨恨。他特意说，我不想让你们在战后迫害南方邦联。不要流血的工作。他说我希望的是你们把领袖们吓出国去，杰斐逊·戴维斯一伙。敞开大门，放下栏杆，把他们吓跑，比如逃到巴黎或者别的什么地方。逃到巴黎。林肯有个有趣的地方。他总是说话很和气，几乎可以说是带着某种慈爱地谈论他的对手。所以他实际上把杰斐逊·戴维斯叫作。他以前叫他杰夫·E·D。听起来像是50年代末的一个小歌手。
Lincoln had made that speech on the 11th of April. But two days later, on the 13th of April, he comes down with this terrible headache. He was going to go for a carriage ride with Mary to go and see gas illuminations that have been put up across Washington to celebrate the victory. He can't go. So they make Ulysses S. Grant go. Mary instead. And guess what? The trip is a total disaster. The crowd cheer Grant and they chant his name. And Mary Lincoln is basically furious. And she actually at one point asked the Carrollistro to stop and let her out because she can't bear it anymore that people are chanting Grant's name and not her husband. I quite like that. I've come into respect her. I think she's
杰夫·E·D。杰夫·E·D和南方邦联。呜呼！是的。或者鲍比·李。
awful. I mean, I literally know nothing about her, beyond what I read in George Sanders' novel. She made me more sympathetic. All right, fair enough. So the next day is the Good Friday, the 14th of April. Lincoln is killed on Good Friday. Yeah. So this Christ-like man is killed on Good Friday. Couldn't make it up. So that morning, the last morning of his life, Lincoln has a meeting of his cabinet with General Grant in attendance. And they are talking about reconstruction again. He says the great question before us, we must soon begin to act. But he says, I am not going to take a hard line on the South. We must extinguish our resentments if we expect harmony and union. He goes out of his way to say, I do not want you to persecute the Confederates after the war. No bloody work. He says what I would like is for you to frighten the leaders out of the country, Jefferson Davis and co. Open the gates, let down the bars, scare them off, as in run away to Paris or something. Run away to Paris. It's a funny thing about Lincoln. He always talks very kindly, almost sort of fondly of his opponents. So he actually called Jefferson Davis. He used to call him Jeff E.D. Sounds like a kind of minor singer in the late
他会叫罗伯特·E·李。鲍比·李非常，是的。是的，那是他的女朋友。不管怎样，内阁会议上的每个人后来都说，林肯当时状态非常好。他头痛刚好。休假了两天。他看起来恢复得很好。
1950s. Jeffrey D. Jeffrey D. and the Confederates. Woo! Yeah. Yeah. Or Bobby Lee.
他的财政部长休·麦卡洛克曾这么说过。我从未见过他如此高兴。重担已经卸下，他的脸上。不再有那种疲惫的神情。它是明亮而愉快的。现在，后来，他和玛丽去坐马车。实际上，他们在这次马车上没有发生激烈的争吵，这很好。她评论说他是多么快乐和顽皮。
He would call Robert E. Lee. Bobby Lee is very much, yeah. Yeah, that's his girlfriend. Anyway, everybody at the cabinet meeting said afterwards, Lincoln was actually in great form. It had this headache. It had a couple of days off. He seems to have done good.
林肯对她说，好吧，这是第一次，我真的觉得战争结束了。他对她说，我们俩以后都必须更快乐。在战争和失去我们亲爱的威利之间，我们一直过得很痛苦。所以威利是那个因伤寒死去的男孩。他们前方有一个美好的夜晚，汤姆。他们要去剧院。所以他们在战争期间经常去剧院。华盛顿实际上有两个剧院，两个大型剧院，
His Treasury Secretary, Hugh McCulloch, had said it. I'd never seen him so happy. The burden had been lifted, his face. no longer had its weary look. It was bright and cheerful. Now, afterwards, he goes for a carriage ride with Mary. And actually, they don't have a massive argument on this carriage ride, which is nice. She comments out how jolly and playful he is.
国家剧院和福特剧院。福特剧院在10街。那是一栋红砖建筑。它被视为非常现代化。它在两年前才由一位名叫约翰·T·福特的戏剧企业家开业。所以他是一个非常谦逊的人。是的，福特剧院，正是如此。
And Lincoln says to her, well, for the first time, I really feel as though the war is over. He says to her, we must both be more cheerful in the future. Between the war and the loss of our darling, Willie, we have been very miserable. So Willie is the boy who died of typhoid. They've got a nice evening out ahead, Tom. They're going to the theatre. So they've gone a lot to the theatre in the war. There are two theatres in Washington, really two big ones,
现在，我很高兴地说，它正在上演一部英国戏剧。一部由汤姆·泰勒编写的嘲讽美国人的英国戏剧《我们的美国表亲》，这是一部闹剧。我其实读过剧本。我掉进兔子洞把剧本读了。它好看吗？
the National and Ford's. Ford's is on 10th Street. It's a red brick building. It's seen as very modern. It was only opened two years earlier by the theatrical entrepreneur called John T. Ford. So he's a very modest man. Yeah, Ford's Theatre, exactly.
太糟糕了。一点也不好笑。这是一部闹剧，基本上讲的是一个来自佛蒙特州的粗鲁乡巴佬，他继承了一户英国贵族家庭的财产，然后他去继承它。期间发生了一系列滑稽的误解。我觉得听起来不错。你可以把这个和布斯扮演希腊雕塑家的那部凑成双剧连演。
Now, it's putting on, I'm delighted to say, a British play. A British play mocking Americans called Our American Cousin' by Tom Taylor. It's a farce. I've actually read the script. I've fell down the rabbit horn, read the script. Is it good?
你还真可以。那会相当有趣。为什么人们不多做一些以约翰·威尔克斯·布斯为主题的娱乐活动呢？这真是一个绝对的谜。现在，《华盛顿晚星报》已经报道了林肯将去观看这场演出。他们报道说他将与尤利西斯·S·格兰特一同前往。剧院因此迎来了一波最后一刻的门票预订潮。他们忙着弄旗帜。他们忙着在演出前安排一组合唱和爱国歌曲之类。这一切都令人兴奋。
It's terrible. It's very unfunny. It's a farce about basically a boorish hick from Vermont, who inherits the fortune of an aristocratic British family, and he goes to claim it. There's a series of comic misunderstandings. I think it sounds good. You could do a double bill of that and the one where Booth played a Greek sculptor.
现在，与此同时，当林肯外出坐马车并与内阁交谈时，约翰·威尔克斯·布斯在做什么呢？他一直呆在华盛顿。他去看过那些灯光照明，那些点亮的鹰和星星之类的东西。他说，你知道，这是一场宏大的展示，但我希望这是一场为崇高事业而进行的展示。但世界就是这样。强权即公理。他非常难过，因为南方输了。那天早上的某个时候——耶稣受难日的早晨，他去了福特剧院。现在他在福特剧院非常出名，因为他是一个——你知道，是一个大演员。
You could actually. That would be quite interesting. Why don't people do more John Walk's Booth? themed entertainment. It's an absolute riddle. Now, the evening star, the Washington Evening Star, has already reported that Lincoln's going to go to this play. And they've reported that he will go with General Grant. And the theatre has had a rush of last minute bookings. And they're rushing to kind of get flags. And they're rushing to sort of do a patriotic
而且他的邮件经常送到那里，也就是他的女性崇拜者寄来的粉丝信。所以想必他对福特剧院了如指掌。了解所有出口，我的意思是，至关重要的是。他知道入口和出口。他甚至认识舞台工人。他对这里了如指掌。当他在取信时，他与剧院经理闲聊，那人是哈里·福特，我想他是约翰·福特的兄弟。布斯说，哦，你听到李在阿波马托克斯投降的消息了吗，他说，我简直心碎了。李，真是个傻瓜。他本该战斗到底的。真是个懦夫，他把事情搞得一团糟。福特对他说，得了吧。我的意思是，他是个将军而你不是。你根本不知道你在说什么。我的意思是，我不得不说布斯是自取其辱。确实如此。确实如此。布斯对此感到极其震惊和沮丧。然后福特说，嘿，猜猜今晚谁要来我们的剧院？林肯总统。而且他要带尤利西斯·S·格兰特一起来。布斯当时显然没有任何反应。他只是坐下来开始看他的信。但很显然，他在动脑筋。因为在接下来的几个小时里，他做了三件事。
lineup beforehand of songs and stuff. It's all very exciting. Now, meanwhile, while Lincoln's off on his carriage ride and talking to his cabinet, what's John Wilkes Booth doing? He's, has stayed in Washington. He had gone to see the illuminations, the lights, you know, lit up kind of eagles and stars and stuff. And he said, you know, it was a great display, but I wish it had been a display in a noble cause. But so goes the world. Might makes right. He's very sad because the South has lost. Sometime that morning, good Friday morning, he goes over to Ford's theatre. Now he's very well known at Ford's Theatre because he's a, you know, he's a big
首先，他去见了一个在剧院附近经营马厩的家伙，一个叫庞弗雷先生的人。他租了一匹棕色的母马，额头上有一颗白色的星星。他说，我一会儿回来牵这匹马。暂时帮我照看一下这匹马。然后他去了那个南方邦联的旅馆，也就是玛丽·萨拉特经营的安全屋。他私下和她谈话，并交给她一个包裹。后来，她出城去了她在马里兰州乡村拥有的一家酒馆，
actor. And he often has mail sent there, kind of fan mail from his female admirers. And so presumably he knows Ford's Theatre like the back of his hand. Knows all the exits, I mean, crucially. He knows the entrance and exit. He knows the stage hands even. He knows it so well. And while he's picking up his post, he chats to the manager of the theatre who's Harry Ford, I think he's John Ford's brother. And Booth says, oh, you've heard the news about Lee surrendering Appomatics, says, I'm absolutely gutted. Lee, what a fool. He should have gone down fighting. What a cow, what a mess he made of that. And Ford says to him, well, come on. I mean, he's a general and you're not. You don't know what you're talking about. I mean, I've got to say Booth walked into that one. He did. He did. Booth is absolutely shocked and downcast by this. And then Ford says, hey, guess he's going to our theatre tonight? President Lincoln. And he's bringing Ulysses S. Grant with him. And Booth apparently showed no reaction at the time. He just sat down and started looking at his post. But clearly, he's thinking. Because in the next few hours, he does three things.
她把这个包裹留在了那里。我们会在下一集里回到这个包裹上来。然后第三件事，在下午的某个时候，布斯联系了三个他曾与之谈论过绑架阴谋的随从。他为这个夜晚做好了安排。
First of all, he goes to see a bloke who runs a stable near the theatre, a man called Mr. Pumfrey. And he hires a brown horse, a mare, with a white star on her forehead. He says, I'll come back for this horse later. Hold on to the horse for the time being. Then he goes to that Confederate lodging house, the safe house run by Mary's Sarat. And he talks to her in private, and he gives her a package. Later, she goes out of the city to a tavern that she owns.
这三个家伙是：一个来自德国的马车修理工，名叫乔治·阿泽罗特；一个来自马里兰州的药剂师助手，名叫大卫·赫罗德；还有一个曾是南方邦联士兵、现在作为南方邦联特工工作的路易斯·鲍威尔。汤姆，我会把这些安排保密，
in the countryside in Maryland, and she leaves this package there. We'll come back to the package in the next episode. And then third thing, at some point in the afternoon, Booth contacts three of the sort of hangers-on who he'd been talking about the kidnap plot too. And he makes arrangements for the evening.
现在我们来到傍晚。在白宫，林肯一家吃过晚饭，正准备出门去剧院。他们耽误了，因为众议院议长——他有着非常出色的美国名字叫谢拉·科尔法克斯——
And these three blokes are, there's a carriage repairman from Germany called George Azarot. There's a pharmacist's assistant from Maryland called David Herald and there's a former Confederate soldier who's now working as a Confederate agent called Lewis Powell and Tom I will keep it in reserve
正等着和他谈论加利福尼亚的事。多米尼克，这样说很公道吧：从这一刻起，疯狂的19世纪美国名字的粉丝们将要乐不思蜀了。是的，因为接下来的名字多得是。确实如此，其实还有很多人被我从故事里删掉了，那些名字听起来像某种杂草之类，比如疯狂的美国名字。我都不得不删掉。所以只要假设——基本上假设背景里有大量带着这种巴洛克式荒谬名字的人。大约在8点30分，与谢拉·科尔法克斯交谈后，林肯一家准备出发了。现在，计划有变。
what these arrangements are so now we come to the evening the White House, the Lincolns have had their dinner they're about to go out to the theatre they're delayed because the speaker of the House of Representatives who has their excellent American name of Shaila Colfax
尤利西斯·S·格兰特被之前与林肯夫人的相处吓怕了，他说，我绝不可能跟这些人一起去剧院。所以原本打算在林肯被刺杀的当晚同行的尤利西斯·S·格兰特退出了。难道人们不觉得这很可疑吗？我的意思是，阴谋论者。天哪，这是一个好观点。难道没有人认为格兰特可能是清除林肯以便自己顺理成章当上总统的阴谋幕后黑手吗？我太喜欢你在录制节目时现场发明阴谋论这个主意了。
is waiting to talk to him about California and Dominic it's fair to say isn't it, that from this point on, fans of mad 19th century American names are going to be in Clover. Yeah, because there's loads of them coming up. There is, and there's actually a lot of people I've cut out of the story
哇。我从没听过这种说法。我觉得这挺可疑的。所以另一个不去、同样讨厌林肯夫人的则是尤莉亚·格兰特。她对格兰特说，如果那个女人在场，我是绝对不会去的。这难道没有引发这种可能性吗：那颗子弹其实是为玛丽·林肯准备的？而且实际上，幕后主使是格兰特夫人。
who people call kind of furlough weed or something, like mad American names. I've had to cut out. So just assume that basically assume that in the background are a lot of people with these Baroque ridiculous names. So about 8.30, after talking to Shaila Colfax, the Lincolns are ready to leave. Now, the plan has changed.
人们称之为类似“ furlough weed”（放假草）之类的东西，全是些疯狂的美国名字。我不得不删掉。所以大家基本上可以默认，在背景里有一大堆带着这种巴洛克风格荒谬名字的人。大约在八点半，在与谢拉·科尔法克斯交谈后，林肯夫妇准备出发了。现在，计划变了。
Ulysses S. Grant has been so burned by his previous encounters with Mrs. Lincoln that he says, there is no way I am going to the theatre with these people. So Ulysses S. Grant was meant to be going on the night that Lincoln is assassinated drops out. Do people not find this suspicious? I mean, conspiracy theorists. Gosh, that's a good point. Does anyone think Grant was perhaps behind the plot to clear Lincoln out of the way so he could, in the due course, become president? I love the idea that you've invented a conspiracy theory.
尤利西斯·S·格兰特之前与林肯夫人的接触中吃尽了苦头，以至于他说，我绝对不可能和这些人一起去剧院。所以原本注定要在林肯遇刺当晚一同前往的尤利西斯·S·格兰特退出了。难道人们不觉得这很可疑吗？我是说，阴谋论者。天哪，这倒是个好主意。难道会有人认为格兰特可能才是清除林肯以扫清自己道路的幕后黑手，好让他顺理成章地当上总统？我真喜欢你现场发明一个阴谋论的点子。
Live while recording a show. Wow. I've never heard that claim. I find that quite suspicious. So the other person who doesn't go, who hates Mrs. Lincoln, is Julia Grant. She says to Grant, I will not go if that woman is there. Does this not raise the possibility that the bullet was meant for Mary Lincoln? And actually, it's Mrs. Grant, who's behind the conspiracy.
在录制节目时直播。哇。我从来没听过这种说法。我发现这相当可疑。所以另一个不去、且讨厌林肯夫人的就是茱莉亚·格兰特。她对格兰特说，如果那个女人在场，我是绝对不会去的。这难道没有引发这种可能性：那颗子弹其实是留给玛丽·林肯的？而实际上，是格兰特夫人才是幕后黑手。
That would be a twist. That is a twist. So they don't go. Now, Lincoln says, oh, if they're not going, I don't really. want to go. And Mary says, you have to go. The press here that you're going. And if none of us go, everyone will be really disappointed. She said, anyway, I've lined up some replacements. My friend, Clara Harris. But she does have a friend. She does have a friend, which is lovely. I was thinking exactly that. She's got at least one friend. She's got Clara Harris, and Clara Harris has her
那可就成反转了。这确实是个反转。所以他们不去了。现在，林肯说，哦，如果他们不去，我其实也不想去了。玛丽说，你必须去。媒体都报道你要去了。如果我们谁都不去，大家会非常失望的。她说，不管怎样，我已经找好替补了。我的朋友，克拉拉·哈里斯。不过她确实有个朋友。她确实有个朋友，这真好。我刚才也是这么想的。她至少有一个朋友。她有克拉拉·哈里斯，而克拉拉·哈里斯有她的
fiance, who's Major Henry Rathbone. So they're going to take these two people. Now, you asked about security. There is very, very little security. They are escorted to the theatre by a police patrolman called John Parker and a White House messenger called Charles Forbes, but they're not professional bodyguards. Lincoln never travels with professional bodyguards. He has said many times I will not be shut up in an iron cage. Now he says, when people say to him, do you not want to be careful? You're fighting a civil war. He says, who would want to kill me? No one would want to kill me. It's not in people's nature to want to kill me. Now, that would seem mad to us today. But the fact is that at the time, there's never been a successful assassination in American history.
未婚夫，也就是亨利·拉思伯恩少校。所以他们打算带上这两个人。现在，你问到安全问题。安保工作非常非常少。他们由一名叫约翰·帕克的巡警和一名叫查尔斯·福布斯的白宫信使护送到剧院，但他们不是专业保镖。林肯出行从来不带专业保镖。他多次说过，我绝不会把自己关在铁笼子里。现在他说，当人们对他说，你难道不想小心点吗？你在打内战。他说，谁会想杀我？没人会想杀我。想杀我不是人的本性。在今天看来，这似乎太疯狂了。但事实是，在当时，美国历史上从未发生过成功的暗杀事件。
And Lincoln's own Secretary of State, William Seward, said in 1862, assassination is not an American practice or habit, and one so vicious and so desperate cannot be engrafted into our political system. That's aged well. Yeah, how wrong he was. So they turn up at Ford's Theatre at 9 o'clock. Now, they're late. The play has been underway for 20 minutes, and they go up to their box.
林肯自己的国务卿威廉·西华德在1862年曾说过，暗杀不是美国的做法或习惯，这种恶毒而绝望的行为不可能被移植到我们的政治体制中。这话可真经不起时间的考验。是的，他错得多么离谱。于是他们在9点钟来到了福特剧院。现在，他们迟到了。戏剧已经开演20分钟了，他们走上了包厢。
So it's actually two boxes which are knocked into one. So the theatre, when they know Lincoln is coming, they have to basically knock two boxes into one. Box is seven and eight. In the box, there are a sofa, an armchair, and a rocking chair that Lincoln will sit in. The box is very conspicuous. It's been hung with American flags for all to see.
所以这实际上是两个打通成一个的包厢。因此，剧院在得知林肯要来时，不得不把两个包厢合二为一。7号和8号包厢。包厢里有一张沙发、一把扶手椅和一把林肯将要坐的摇椅。这个包厢非常显眼。里面挂满了美国国旗，供所有人瞻仰。
Lincoln goes in. The audience turns to look at him. The play stops. It's actually stop the play. The band plays Hail to the Chief. Everybody applauds. Lincoln smiles. Lincoln bows.
林肯走了进去。观众转过身来看他。戏剧停演了。实际上是暂停了戏剧。乐队演奏了《统帅万岁》。所有人都鼓掌。林肯微笑着。林肯鞠躬。
And the play resumes. Everybody is roaring with laughter. They think this is a brilliant play. Lincoln is watching it. He seems very intent on it. He's kind of laughing to himself. And yet Tom, all the time, his killer is coming closer and closer.
戏剧接着上演。每个人都在放声大笑。他们觉得这是一部精彩的戏剧。林肯正在观看。他看起来非常专注。他自己也在暗笑。然而，汤姆，与此同时，他的凶手正一步步逼近。
So we get to 10.15. Now on stage, the American cousin, who is played by an actor called Harry Hawk, has been arguing with his British relative, Mrs. Mount Chessington. That's a very British name. Doesn't it sound like a great play? It sounds brilliant.
时间到了10点15分。现在在舞台上，由演员哈里·霍克饰演的美国表亲，正在与他的英国亲戚芒特切辛顿夫人争吵。这是一个非常英国的名字。这听起来不像是一部好戏吗？听起来太棒了。
Do you have an example of the brilliant dialogue from the play? I do. Mrs. Mount Chessington says to this bloke, you don't know the manners of good society, and she storms off. And Harry Hawke, playing the American cousin, says, I don't know the manners of good society, eh? Well, I guess I know enough to turn you inside out, old gal, you sock-dologizing old man-trap.
你有什么剧中精彩对话的例子吗？有的。芒特切辛顿夫人对这个家伙说，你不懂上流社会的礼仪，然后她气冲冲地走了。扮演美国表亲的哈里·霍克说，我不懂上流社会的礼仪，是吗？好吧，我想我懂得怎么把你里朝外翻过来，老太婆，你这个自作聪明的陷阱。
Everybody laughs. The whole theatre erupts in laughter. On stage, this bloke, Harry Hawk, he turns to walk off stage. And at that moment, the door of Abraham Lincoln's presidential box swings open and standing in the doorway is John Wilkes Booth. Well, if people want to know what happens next, there's literally only one way to do it. And that is either to wait until Thursday to find out. what happens to President Lincoln, or if you're a member of the rest of history club, you can go straight ahead and listen to it now.
全场大笑。整个剧院爆发出阵阵笑声。在舞台上，这个叫哈里·霍克的家伙转身走下舞台。就在那一刻，亚伯拉罕·林肯总统包厢的门猛地被推开，门后站着约翰·威尔克斯·布思。好吧，如果人们想知道接下来会发生什么，老实说只有一个办法。那就是要么等到周四去揭晓总统林肯的命运，要么如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你可以直接去听。
If you're not a member of the rest of history club, but you would like to find out whether President Lincoln survives or not, you can go to the rest is history.com. And on that gunshot, goodbye. Goodbye. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你不是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，但又想知道林肯总统是否幸存，你可以访问 theriesishistory.com。伴随着那声枪响，再见。再见。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。